want to be happy build a life not just a
business hey it's evan carmichael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know there's something more inside
youtube you've got michael jordan level
genius at something so today let's live
your best believe life and get some
incredible motivation from the one and
only john assaraf enjoy
there is
a misconception
that business is easy
and
i have a lot of clients of mine for
example that are there are doctors and
lawyers and professionals that have an
expertise
in a certain area
but nobody's ever taught them about
finance
about
legal
if they're not a lawyer about marketing
about sales
about technology about operations about
management
and being an entrepreneur is like
solving a rubik's cube
yes i see that right so you can have the
two by two with two colors you know it's
easy
if you want a little bit bigger business
that's three by three there's more
combinations and more things that need
to be considered
four by four now has billions of
different moves just four by fours
billions of different possibilities wow
when you get to the 8 by 8 or 16 by 16
rubik's cube
there's quintillions of possible moves
that you can make
so
building a business is all about
recognizing patterns
and knowing
which
move to make at the right time
and there's four options that you have
one is
do it yourself and try and figure it out
two is get help
three get it done for you or four don't
do it did you know that some of the most
recent studies on setting goals and
writing them out or typing them out on
your computer will actually increase
your chances of achieving those goals by
up to 42 percent
why well as soon as you put the energy
to writing out your goals and getting
clarity you're giving your brain the
instruction that this is what's
important to you this is what you want
to achieve so don't be like all the
other people where they have goals and
dreams and they hope and pray for it to
work
be the type of person who sets her goals
or his goals in writing and then focus
on that every day and you'll achieve
more of your goals there's something in
the um
weight loss industry field called the
fat set point
and every brain has a fat set point and
it basically states that you have a set
point just like a thermostat that's
programmed in a room to have a set point
we have fat set points we have financial
set points we have relationship set
points we have these
set points that we become accustomed to
achieving and then all of the supporting
evidence the stories the themes the plot
lines the perceptions and behaviors all
must match the set point
and so you can ask yourself two
questions number one is how did that set
point get there and then how do i change
it right so how it got there is through
all of your conditioning
through what you've read what you've
done what you've experienced what you've
been told what you've seen all of that
has created
your financial set point based on your
story
and so the first thing to recognize is
the set point can be changed
and the question is how
right and that's the million dollar
question so number one
what drives behavior more than anything
else it's not skill it's not knowledge
skill and knowledge is potential power
but what does drive behavior or anything
else is beliefs
and so if there is a belief
in the brain that says yes you know i
think i'm capable of achieving double my
income would just use double my income
but there's another
belief that opposes that that causes
what we
we know is as neural
dissonance so it creates a chaotic
vibration in the brain between the
conscious and non-conscious mind so the
key is to get alignment between the new
goal which is a conscious pattern of
thought that you can choose in an
instant
and the non-conscious
part of the brain around that goal so
how do you develop a belief right so
it's a pattern so
if i gave you a sentence
and you said that sentence one time you
probably it's great to be a sentence
like when i was like hearing a line in a
song one time but if you heard a line in
a song
repeatedly 20 30 40 50 times and you had
other associations with that to
reinforce that pattern then you would
start to develop a non-conscious pattern
through that so we know that using let's
say visualization you're actually
bypassing the conscious mind and you're
accessing
the visual cortex of the brain it's a
non-conscious process the visual
processor
and so if we take words and we affirm
them and we feel them and we visualize
and repeat them 100 200 500 000 times
now we start to create a pattern at the
non-conscious level that basically
reinforces a conscious desire every
level of success that you want to
achieve in health wealth relationships
career business etc requires
a new understanding of a skill
and a new behavioral pattern what got
you to where you are
is not enough to get you to where you
want to go
why do i say that
because if it was enough to get you to
where you want to go you would already
be there so what got you here will not
get you there maybe some stepping stones
but every level of success requires
a new
level of skill and behavior and i'm
going to go back to one of the other
lessons
since we develop beliefs and habits and
behaviors that go from conscious effort
to non-conscious habits
in order to achieve the next level of
success you have to learn how to create
new habits of thought new emotional
management skills and new behaviors to
match the level of success that you want
to achieve i'm always looking for
consistency
around all of my content does that make
sense to you if it makes sense just tell
me john that makes total sense so so far
we have you know define what your brand
stands for if your brand could speak
what would your brand say about you
right if your brand could speak
what would your brand say about you is
your brand fast is your brand slow is
your brand laxie daisical or just a just
free flow bohemian you know or is it
more you know um more sharp edges um so
you have to think about this and that if
you're looking to build a personal brand
if you're looking to build a personal
brand then you need to think about what
does my brand stand for what do i want
people to think and feel
about my personal brand so that i own
some space okay in their brain so let me
ask you a question let's have a little
bit of fun when i share with you um the
personal brand
oprah what do you
feel about the brand what do you feel
about the brand
is it a brand that you trust
is it a brand that is fast or calm
like what do you feel when you hear the
word oprah or what do you feel when you
hear the you know the um the brand elon
musk
right what do you what does it make you
feel because every brand develops
consistency and the consistency creates
a feeling and people gravitate towards
how a brand makes them feel right
does a brand make you feel appreciated
that you can trust it uh that it's safe
or that it's risky like elon musk is a
risk taker right he's a different brand
than oprah and yet he's got a huge
following he will make a comment and you
know and cryptocurrency goes through the
roof
right so what does your brand stand for
not having a sales process what does
that mean
so let me share with you
just a sales process so you need to
think
in systems
right if this and this and this and this
happens then x is predictable
so let's say you are going to um
do a instagram live
facebook live youtube live linkedin live
event
you have to think past the event
you have to think past the event
then what
like if somebody comes to your event if
somebody reads your blog if somebody um
reads your twitter feed if somebody
watches your tick tock
like then what
like
what is the process by which you share
your
product service or knowledge information
tidbits around the things that you want
to share
then what like what do you want them to
do next
now before you ask people to do
something like give you their email oh i
want your email before you ask them to
you know sign up for this free event or
this paid event
you have to give them value
right give them value give them
something tangible
and don't be afraid to give give give
give when i wrote my book intersize all
of my books
everything that i write in my books
is
the stuff in my head that i'm working
with clients who pay me five thousand
dollars an hour they just want to go
deeper on the work for me to help them
implement it
but i wanna give give give give value
value value value and then i can say hey
if you want to go deeper
get my books you want to go deeper
get my programs you want to go deeper
get into my coaching program you want to
go deeper hire me as a consultant but
first
give the knowledge so here's the
question that you want to ask yourself
what
problem does your product or service
solve
what fear does it eliminate
what pain does it eliminate uh what gain
do people have because of the product
whenever i am looking to give people
content i'm always looking at
understanding
what are the pains fears frustrations
irritations wants needs and aspirations
let me repeat what are
the pains fears frustrations irritations
wants needs and aspirations of
the person who wants to buy
whatever it is you know that i have to
offer doesn't mean there's somebody sold
all this stuff by the way here's my
gratitude coin right
gratitude so so you know whether it's
glasses spray a pen a magnifying glass
uh a gratitude coin uh the camera that
i'm looking into the computer the stand
somebody had to sell that and every
single product or service
either eliminates a pain fear for space
irritation or helps people with a want
need or aspiration right
so how do you give somebody
content and information and value in
advance
and i'll sit on my board or on my
keyboard and i will ask what is it that
people want and need that i could help
them with
and then i create whether it's blogs
articles
videos process maps and i give them away
lack of knowledge and skills
so lack of knowledge and skills so
when we don't have let's say we have a
goal
any goal it doesn't make a difference
whether it's a relationship goal money
charity whatever it is whenever we lack
the knowledge or the skills
there's a part of us that has self-doubt
self-doubt is what triggers
fear
because we're worried we don't know
enough right so if we don't know enough
if we don't have the knowledge or the
skill or we think we have to have this
certain knowledge or skill
um that we don't have or that you know
that we think we need it's going to
trigger self-doubt self-doubt triggers
fear fear deactivates motivational
centers in the brain and deactivates the
thinking part of the brain in our
imagination
it's circuits it's all it is is circuits
turning on or off yes
and so in the absence of knowledge and
skill of what to do about it
we default to not taking action because
we're protecting ourselves
right and so all of these little
mechanisms you know these four
key ones um
cause us to trigger the uh
procrastination circuit in the brain
they do not take action circuit in the
brain yes
right and you know guys or girls when
they're dating you know if they feel
uncertain then they just stay there well
maybe he'll come and talk to me well
maybe she'll come and talk to me and and
it just goes round and round and round
and round how do you
recognize and overcome fear well you you
pay attention uh you become mindful uh
you sit
and um
take some deep breaths and ask yourself
some really good questions
what fears are holding me back like
like just get real get real with
yourself don't be afraid
be afraid of the truth um if you
understand the truth and then you have
some knowledge and skills to work
through
you can change that so
the
take six com the circuits is the first
inner size i'm going to give you a
slight variation of take six calm the
circuits as you do the next inner size
and it's called ayah awareness intention
and action so
in this particular inner size uh you
take six rhythmic deep breaths
to calm the circuits but here's a slight
variation this is like a little bit more
advanced right so what you do is as you
breathe in
you say in the back of your mind i
breathe in calmness
i breathe out fear so it goes like this
so as you are breathing in calmness
feel yourself getting calm from a level
10 fearful to eight to six to four
to two to just letting go of the fear
and as you breathe in calmness and you
breathe out fear i want you to visualize
fear
leaving
your body just release it remember it's
a neurochemistry that you're feeling so
what you do
is you give your brain the instruction
of what you want so i breathe in
calmness i breathe out fear or i breathe
in calmness i breathe out stress or i
breathe in calmness i breathe out
anxiety
just
a few seconds of that
is the first part of the inner size but
then what you do
is then you say you know right after you
do that you now become aware and have a
piece of paper next to you and in the
awareness state what you want to do is
become aware
awareness of thoughts
feelings
emotions
sensations and behaviors thoughts
feelings emotions sensations and
behaviors so the first part is you
become aware
no shame no blame no guilt no judgment
no justification just pure awareness
then you ask yourself in this calm
relaxed state where you're able to
respond you ask yourself
what's my intention right now is my
intention to be fearful
no is my intention to be courageous
yes is my intention to overcome my fear
yes great so you have the awareness you
set one intention not five one
one intention
and then the last a
is
action
what is one action i could take
what action towards
achieving whatever goal i have so maybe
one action is i'm gonna write one uh
line of my book one action is i'm gonna
just make one phone call one action is
going to ask for help one action to move
you away
from what you don't want you have to
create
marketing
content and
offers irresistible offers that people
want
to move towards because it really helps
them
it really helps them okay
and so when
you are asking somebody to buy something
first did you offer value in advance to
build trust and rapport
second
did you create a process for them to be
able to easily move through
from knowledge and information
to making a decision that's good and
helpful to them
and then
did you create
an offer that is irresistible for them
an offer that's irresistible for them
that of course you make a profit on you
have to make a profit you're in business
to make a profit and to help people so
what i want you to do
is when you are thinking about
how to structure
your business how to structure your
offers how to structure your marketing
so you stand out from the competition
now
you have an opportunity to really grow
your business so that it actually works
for you unfortunately
most business owners have a job that
they work in their business they don't
have a business they're entrepreneurs i
get it but they have a job
your job is to create really great
marketing
that gives people a lot of what they
need to help them
okay with their pains fears frustrations
irritations wants needs and aspirations
your job is to give value in advance on
the channel
that your ideal client is at
and then your job is to create a sales
process
that makes it easy for them to do
business with you instead of somebody
else
it's easy but it's also easy not to do
the golden nugget specifically for
entrepreneurs
is something that i was taught 37 years
ago by my mentor who was a very
successful entrepreneur
and he said
take one hour a day to level up your
skills
he says when you do one hour a day to
level up your skills whether it's your
mental skills emotional skills strategic
skills whatever it is but one hour a day
after 365 days is 9 40 hour weeks that
you will be ahead of anybody who isn't
doing that so one year it's 9 40 hour
weeks nine of them that's two and a half
months
do that for two years three years four
years you will become an expert and you
will make millions of dollars you'll be
happy you'll be not because the millions
dollars you'll you'll you'll be able to
live the lifestyle of your dreams
because of who you've become
by upgrading your knowledge and skills
and abilities by just one hour a day so
patterns that have been reinforced
for 20 30 40 50 years
they're strong patterns
they're really strong patterns
so you don't change a 20 or 30 year old
pattern
in 20 days
by doing it 20 times or 30 times or 50
times when the other pattern has been
recreated and reinforced thousands and
thousands of times you operate your
whole day your whole week your whole
month your whole year based on the
patterns that have been there put there
and reinforced yes so what if i said you
train your brain for 100 days
and replace the old disempowering or
negative or destructive patterns with a
new pattern but deliberately yes
deliberate it's called deliberate
conscious evolution i'm deliberately
going to choose to change myself
and if you committed to that think about
what what would happen if we said let's
say you're out of shape
and we said you know what um let's go
for a one minute walk every day not an
hour one minute yep so the first you
know week we go wow this is easy one
minute walk i can just walk around my
house for a minute here's my guarantee
will happen
at the end of one week just so let's do
a minute and a half
and let's do two minutes and then let's
do three minutes and then at 100 days
you might be at let's say you're at an
hour 100 days later because you actually
enjoy it
what do you think would happen to your
beliefs to your confidence your physique
to everything if you were to exercise
gently lightly for one hour a day change
your life completely transform so let's
start with self-talk let's start with
eliminating our self-deprecating you
know discussions with ourselves
and if we want to change our limiting
beliefs why not start with asking what
empowering beliefs do i want to have
and then what are ways that i could
actually create that pattern in my brain
so reading an affirmation
and closing your eyes and actually
feeling what that's like if it was true
and how would you behave if that was
true and what kind of comments would you
get if that was true
activates
not only the left prefrontal cortex of
your brain the occipital lobe part of
your brain the emotional part of your
brain and the motor cortex of your brain
but that is what it requires to rewire
the brain with a new more empowering
pattern because
i felt dumb
i read thousands of books and did
hundreds of courses
and because i didn't feel like i was
smart enough
i
took the
thing that could have
i guess made my life a mess
and turned it into my fuel for success
and because
i lived with parents that
didn't have a great marriage
i ended up
divorcing twice
but because of all of those things
i studied and researched
and and dove deep into who do i need to
be to have a great relationship what
communication skills must i have
who
can i model that had a great
relationship and
i'm afraid
not to do it now
so people ask me like when do you stop
never when
when they bury me
is when i'll stop
i am i have such a habit of working on
me
learning more becoming more more loving
more caring more kind more generous more
giving more
like where do you stop and it's not a
matter of of acquiring more
i'm not gonna eat any differently for
the rest of my life than i eat now
you know i'm not gonna eat bigger you
know meals i'm not gonna
do things too much differently than i am
now so now it's a matter
of expression and expanding more to do
more good in the world
so in order for me to do more good in
the world i have to expand even my own
mindset i've got to
get away from the fears that i have
of maybe not being good enough or not
being smarter i still get those feelings
but because of my daily rituals and my
daily practices
i give back to my spiritual center my
spiritual core and a little bit more
confident and a little bit more certain
every day
towards the goals that i want to achieve
and i bridge that gap and then when i
reach those goals
keep doing it again the more you can
create
success rituals
processes and systems daily success
rituals
to activate your motivational centers
your
emotional centers and behaviors the more
you can create daily rituals of how you
start a day
how you deal with stress during the day
how you plan your day how you evaluate
your day how you follow through to the
end of the day in a process that puts
you in a cycle of success
the easier it becomes to achieve success
and to make that the default mode of the
brain once you understand that the power
center is right within you and you learn
how to just use the tools a little bit
better we've got the most powerful three
pound tool in the world with no user's
manual right so
and and so we teach people here's the
latest research here's how you can apply
to your life to be healthy or happier
make more money get a better job get a
raise start your business and do better
by retraining your brain
to be totally and aligned with your
goals and dreams and like in learning
how do i stay focused how do i stay
motivated
how do i stay on track how do i develop
the habits that will empower me and how
do i do the things that inspire me
instead of the things that expire me you
all know that you have a conscious
part of your brain
that's responsible for certain
things okay
but then you also have a subconscious
part of the brain subconscious and so
what is
this 800 pound gorilla
that prevents you from achieving your
goals like what is it like what do you
think it is about the subconscious
that prevents you from achieving your
goals when consciously you want to
achieve your goals right um
consciously you want to achieve your
goals and uh k
camiar yeah we have you know right
hemisphere and left hemisphere of the
brain and in between
okay we have something called the corpus
callosum that connects both hemispheres
and
contrary to popular belief
we're not you know left brain dominant
or right brain dominant we use all of
our brain uh every 24 hours so you don't
use only five or ten percent of your
brain
um
the possibilities are endless
all right but when
you're talking about the gorilla the
subconscious is is the you know what i
what i talk about in the book right is i
named it the gorilla
so conscious and subconscious yes
and so tell me what you know about the
subconscious mind like if it is the 800
pound gorilla what do we know
right
the gorilla gets what the gorilla wants
and so if you ask yourself a question
of
do i really know how
to get my subconscious mind
aligned with my conscious desires and
goals
so answer that question for me answer me
that riddle do you know how to get your
subconscious mind by the way the
subconscious is not like here and the
conscious is here
we know that
the left prefrontal cortex for example
um is the seat of you know awareness and
it's the seat of decision making it's a
seat
of choosing what we want we know that
this part of the brain we call the left
prefrontal cortex and it's what i call
is the
einstein part of the brain
it can figure things out you consciously
can figure things out
the right prefrontal cortex
is the pessimist or what i refer to as
the frankenstein part of the brain that
moves into the memory system and brings
forth anything that may uh get you into
trouble anything may be painful anything
that
might hurt you
and so there's these
these things going on in the brain if
you think of your brain as an orchestra
and
some of your
brain um
is responsible to play certain pieces
and other parts of your brain are
there to protect you
when those pieces uh oppose each other
or are not in alignment
then you have
chaos the fascination that i have is um
around living in a world
right now where we have access to
all the how to
how do i make more money how do i grow
my business how do i have a great
relationship how do i you know find the
love of my life how do i put a rocket
ship on mars
and
a lot of people are confusing having
information and how to
with actually doing it
and
i've been fascinated just in
understanding how do i help people
unleash more of their potential that
already exists
and a lot of people may have heard you
know they say that
we only use five to ten percent of our
brain that's not true we use a hundred
percent of our brains capacity neural
networks every moment of every day
but
the potential
to use more
is there and so our researchers at
neurogym
really are uncovering how to take the
best information from the world of
neuropsychology neuroscience and give it
to everyday people so they could say
okay how do i overcome my fear of not
being good enough my fear of not being
smart off my fear of
being embarrassed or ridiculed or
ashamed or fear of
failure or fear of success these are all
psychological issues that everybody
feels
but very few people understand when i
feel that what do i do about it so that
i can unlock more of my potential so i
can actually take more action first on
the things i already know
that i could be and should be doing but
i'm not
and next on the behaviors that i could
be taking to achieve my success easier
and faster and that's really my my
passion is helping people unlock that
amazing potential within them the
beautiful thing about the time that
we're living in now
is we can share knowledge
and experiences
and anybody with a you know a phone an
ipad or a smartphone or an android or a
computer
anywhere in the world in the kalahari
desert in antarctica can get access
and get inspired it's the best ideas in
the world yeah to get the best ideas in
the world but to see that
we're no different none of us are
different the illusion
is that we're different because we're
comparing who we are
compared to the person that we're
listening to or learning from or we're
seeing the gap
and the gap
is what causes us to be uncomfortable
but if we remember
we're all spiritual we're all made from
the exact same thing
you know if you think about the human
body it's made of hydrogen oxygen
nitrogen carbon
helium there's there's elements but we
came from the furnaces of stars
you can't have carbon
okay in the human body that didn't come
from the inside of a star
helium and hydrogen is what the big bang
was initially made up of
and then as all the gases coalesced and
created stars and then galaxies
we became
our flesh and blood and everything that
we became the organism has come from the
universal intelligence that's why we're
all connected and that's why we all have
the same abilities different skills
different knowledge but the same
abilities to become
all of the ideas
goals and dreams that we have
and so we just have to say that is what
i want to trade my life for
and even though i don't know how even
though i may not feel totally
comfortable or confident or i'm lacking
certainty
let's get let's get on the path
and then we can change the world
together everybody can imagine for a
moment you're driving a car and
everything's going great and all of a
sudden a light pops up on your dash
now the average person won't take a
hammer and hit the light to turn it off
an average person will take a look at
what is that light am i low on
windshield wiper fluid am i low on air
in my tires is my back trunk open what's
going on
so just like the signal in a car
is meant to make you aware
fear is a trigger in our subconscious
mind that real or imagined danger
has percolated in our brain
and so
fear there's nothing wrong with fear we
can actually use fear as fuel
now i like to you know give people
visuals so imagine if you have you know
two parts of your brain there's many
more but imagine these two we have the
einstein brain and we have the
frankenstein brain and when fear gets
activated let's assume that that's our
frankenstein brain going what if
what if
you get hurt what if you lose money what
if you die what if you get embarrassed
ashamed ridiculed or judged and so where
why does frankenstein even get activated
because we're not born with those fears
and so if we're not born with those
fears that means that something in our
brain is triggering this reaction
automatically without our thought
and that is what we call is the fear
response and we also know that that fear
response
causes something called the sympathetic
nervous system to activate
which causes us to want to fight freeze
or run away that's just the absolute
reaction at a biological level of what
is happening now
when we want to deactivate that
sympathetic nervous system there's
several what i call our inner sizes that
we can do
that actually gives us more control more
power and the ability to reactivate the
einstein part of the brain so inner size
number one
is really really simple it's called take
six calm the circuits so as soon as you
catch yourself
in a state of
doubt
fear worry anxiety stress
that means that frankenstein's activated
if you just took six deep breaths in
through your nose as slowly as you could
and then you exhaled as if you're
exhaling through a straw in your mouth
if you just that did that six times that
very simple inner size would deactivate
the frankenstein brain and allow you to
reactivate your thinking imagination
einstein part of your brain and then you
can do the second inner side which puts
you right back in control and that one i
call is i aia
which is now a matter of awareness
awareness of my thoughts emotions
feelings sensations or the behaviors
that i've just taken or the one i'm
afraid to take
and in a pure state of awareness without
judgment blame shame guilt or
justification
let me repeat without any judgment blame
shame guilt or justification
of the feeling or the thought of the
behavior
now i'm empowered again because now i
can observe and now in this
observational mode i could say okay
what's my intention let's say for the
next 10 minutes
well my intention is to be happy great
my intention is to be productive great
my intention is to you know take action
on this one thing that's going to help
me towards my goal and dream
so in the awareness and in the intention
then if i say what's one small action
step i could take towards what i want
instead of what i don't want
so all of a sudden i've interrupted a
fear pattern
i've created this state of awareness
i've set an intention and now i'm taking
action towards what i want versus being
paralyzed by what i don't want and a
fear that may or may not be real so
awareness is what actually gives us
choice and choice is what actually gives
us freedom if we make the right choices
we all have these patterns
that are subconscious
that are driving our behaviors more than
our conscious efforts
and so
when
we're dealing with the gorilla in the
brain and again it's a metaphorical way
to look at it
you have to understand that the gorilla
is going to get whatever the gorilla is
wired to get the gorilla
does not care about what you consciously
want
the gorilla
really focuses on the patterns that are
gonna keep it safe and here's what safe
means safe just means comfort zone let's
say you're miserable let's say you're
broke let's say you're overweight let's
say you're in a relationship that you
you don't like let's say you're a job
you don't love
that
is safe to the gorilla why because it
knows the pain it's already dealing with
it knows the discomfort it knows the
price it's paying already
versus getting out of that comfort zone
leaving the job that you're not happy
with leaving a relationship that you're
not in love with um
trying to earn more income getting out
of debt you could be in debt and
comfortable you could be in a
relationship you hate and comfortable
you can be in a job that you don't love
and comfortable and the gorilla is gonna
keep you in your comfort zone when i was
19 years old okay
when i had a mentor a man who was in his
50s very very successful
he agreed to to mentor me and to teach
me what he knew
and so he sent me home
with some paper
and on the paper it said
what do you want to achieve in your
health
what do you want to achieve in your
relationships what do you want to
achieve financially
what do you want to achieve charity
what do you want to achieve as far as
experiences
when do you want to retire by how much
money do you want to make
how he asked me about 10 pages of
questions and at 19
i had no idea
how much do i want to make i want to
make enough to pay my bills i want to
make enough to you know just eat well
and then have some fun i want to go
drinking with my friends i want to go
party and travel a little bit and pay
for my apartment than a nice car and
things like that
but he had me think you know one year
five years
25 years and i was 19
and he made me write down
the answers to these questions even
though they were
i had no idea how to achieve them he
made me write it down it took me a whole
weekend and i went back and he looked at
my papers
and so he looked at health and wealth
and relationships and career and
business and he goes
good way to do the exercise i'm very
proud of you he says now i want you to
increase that amount
and so i said that you know by the time
i was 45 i was 19.
i said by the time i was 45
i was going to be a millionaire
nobody in my family
was a millionaire not my aunts not my
uncles not my cousins nobody in the area
that we lived in and i wrote that down
and he said no that's not enough
he says you could do better than that
and i'm like
i'm swallowing i'm scared i'm afraid
how am i going to become
more than that how can i
have all of this he says don't worry
about the how right now
you worry only and not even worry but
you write down what you want
and so i went back home
and started to write again about the
game and and took another you know half
a day to to redo my goals
and he said to me great now in order for
you
to achieve those goals
what do you have to believe
wow i said well i have to believe that i
can
i have to believe that i deserve it
and even though i didn't believe that i
deserved it she said what would you
think you had to believe
i have to believe that it could be done
i have to believe that i could learn the
skills i would have to believe so he
made me write out what i would have to
believe good question
and then he said great what do you think
you would have to do every day
wow
an amazing question
well i guess i would have to
come to work every day and i'd have to
really get good at what i'm doing and
i'd have to learn more that i'm learning
right now because i hated to learn back
then and i'd have to
you know gain more skills which i didn't
have any
the only thing i was good at was i had
an easy time talking to people like i am
with you now
and he said great well
let's make a list of all of these things
and let's come up with a plan
to do this
he said so every day let's look at some
beliefs
and so every day he would have me look
at my goals
and i would sit in my chair
and i'd have my goals you know that he
had me right
and i would take my fingers which he
told me to touch my goals so that i
would send a message to my brain as i
was reading it and seeing it to
reinforce
the goals that i wrote
then i would read
the beliefs
that i needed to have
i
have all the intelligence i need to
achieve these goals
i can now
acquire all the skills to achieve these
goals and i read about 20 or 30
different beliefs every day
and for the first month or two months
while i was reading all of this
in my head this one word
kept coming up you know what the word
was
because as i would read it my brain
would say
that's not true
and he told me that my brain would try
to talk to me
and tell me it's not true and he said if
you keep doing it over and over and over
again
your brain is going to get tired of
telling you it's not true
and especially if after you
do this
you take some actions
to upgrade your knowledge upgrade your
skills
you'll develop more confidence and more
certainty
so he taught me
how to use the telephone to make
telephone calls to people
to see if they were interested in buying
a real estate property or selling their
home i was in real estate at 19.
and you know for the first month it was
hard second month it was hard the third
month it was hard but as i got better
and more comfortable at being on the
telephone talking to people that i
didn't know that i thought didn't want
to hear hear from me or talk to me
i found one person then two people then
three people then five people who said
yes
because as i became more comfortable as
i became more skilled as i gained more
knowledge
people received me differently
and in my first year i made thirty
thousand dollars i was nineteen
which was five thousand dollars more
than my father made as a taxi driver
then he started to upgrade my skills a
little bit more
and he started to teach me some very
specific
things to do in real estate
and in my second year at 20 i made 151
000
wow
five times more
changed my life so um vision board for
seeing what you want
um the accomplished board for reminding
yourself that you've got a lot to uh
that you've accomplished so you feel
good and the crap do you actually put up
images of things you've accomplished
uh-huh yeah yeah i have them in my
closet in my home
uh encased uh on the floor
like on the floor so that you don't look
at them so you know i look at no so i
look at them just because i i i sit down
to put on my shoes i want to look at
them every day interesting yeah on my um
i have i have this ritual as well i do
something called brush and prime so on
my
bathroom
mirror i have my goals that are on my
mirror so that as i'm brushing my teeth
i'm priming my brain to see my goals in
front of me every morning and every
night i love that right so that's
priming your brain which is a whole
other topic we can have and then the
accomplishment boards reminds me
whenever i look at the stuff that have
accomplished i go
that wasn't easy i mean there was a lot
of ups downs highs lows failures you
know times i thought i'd quit and i
didn't so it's to remind me to go
through the times
that i don't think i'm gonna be able to
achieve those things and then the crap
board stands for conflict
resistance
accomplishments
and procrastination
so what conflicts are are happening
right now that i need to resolve
what resistance is in my way is what are
my resistance what in front of me is
resisting right now
and then accomplishment as well is to
remind you that you can get through
stuff and then procrastination is what's
causing me to procrastinate
so if you create a crap board as well
you have that in front of you and then
you can create a game plan for what am i
going to do about it what am i going to
do about the conflict if you think about
what makes up who we are so obviously
there's genetics there's our genetic
makeup so our pre-disposition our
propensities
and that makes up a percentage of how we
see the world and how we show up but
then the rest of it we're trained on so
we're trained to see the world of
surgery so there are certain people that
have something called the negativity
bias and a negativity bias is nothing
more than they see the negative first
it's not that they don't see the
positive but they see the negative first
there's other people who see positive
first they have a positivity biased and
they see that first and the truth is in
almost every situation in every
circumstance there's both
you can train somebody
to recognize that there's always both
just like every inside has an outside
every one side of a coin has another
side of a coin every up has a down
that's called the law of polarity and in
the universe that we live in there is
that law of polarity and so you can
teach somebody say okay if you're
propensity if the way you naturally are
is negativity bias first great be aware
of that then flip over we call it flip
the switch so if one side of your brain
is going negativity first great learn to
flip the switch go great what's the
positive side of that that's a skill you
can learn no differently than playing
tennis or chess or music
when you sit down to meditate do you
come with an intention then each time
no i i i
when once i sit down
then i ask my intuition hey
what is it that you want to be doing
today what is it that you need today so
we all have this intuition which is
different than our instinct but this
intuition
right it's what we know before we think
and so when i sit down and say okay um
hey
uh what's what's the intention for today
and sometimes the intention is to just
let go and see what happens
sometimes the intention is i'm searching
for you know for an answer
uh sometimes the intention is well today
focus you know today let go today just
breathe
so i just listen i just it's just it's
it's the the art
and the subtle science of paying
attention
back in 1987 when i bought the
franchising rights for re max of indiana
um
i had no idea how to build a company i
was you know 26 years old and um but i
had another mentor who i invested 75 000
to become his partner to have the
opportunity to learn from this man who
at the time was worth probably a hundred
million dollars
and so i was very very uh keen on
learning and i didn't know how to build
a business i didn't know anything other
than how to sell real estate
and i set a goal uh to
generate one billion dollars a year in
sales and i set the goal for five years
in the future
not knowing
a billion dollar goal is like
mind-boggling big for me
and i there was an interview um the
second week i was in indianapolis i
moved from toronto to indianapolis for
this opportunity
and um i was interviewed by the
indianapolis business journal and i said
in the interview that was at a goal for
a billion dollars and the reporter said
are you aware that there's two companies
that have been in the state of indiana
for 80 years 100 years the other one and
they haven't hit a billion dollars in
real estate sales in all of these years
and i said yeah i know it's graves and
tucker and you can let them know that
i'll be the first
right and as i said that i almost felt
like i put my foot right in my mouth
because i didn't know how i was gonna do
it right long story short five years
later we sold enough franchise recruit
enough agents we did 1.2 billion dollars
and we were we were stuck which is a
great place to be stuck
and i was asking myself how is it
possible
that i'm training these agents with
strategies with tactics with selling
skills marketing skills we were like the
gurus of here's the books here's the
cassettes here's the trainers here's
like out of the deep end and the agents
who for example would make 30 000 a year
kept making 30 thousand a year the
agents who made fifty kept making fifty
they made a hundred kept making a
hundred and so i realized that they
weren't missing the skills or the
knowledge
there was something else at play and
what helped me from the age of 19 to 27
28 30 was every single day and i still
do it today i'll share this with with
you in just a little bit every single
day i was priming my brain with the
beliefs and the self image required to
achieve the goals that i wanted when we
talk about reprogramming
i think the the important thing to
understand is 99.9
of what we think what we feel what we do
although most people think
i'm in control i'm the one doing it it's
really non-conscious patterns that are
repeating themselves over and over again
so let me explain
when you and i were born
the only
neural networks that we had were for
survival
right we didn't have any beliefs of are
we good enough are we smart enough are
we worthy um we didn't have any
experiences to show us that that's a
scary situation that one's not snakes
are safe or snakes are dangerous or
spiders or heights or whatever the case
is
so over the course of the first seven to
ten years of our life
our brains plasticity switch our brains
switch that connects all of these
neurons and creates the neural map in
our brain is is being created in the
form of millions of connections per
second by time we're 10 or 12 years old
that switch basically goes off and now
there's more selective
okay creation of neural patterns based
on what we like what we dislike
what we experience what our parents tell
us what our teachers tell us up until
that time we're just an empty open
nest where everything's being formulated
and so what happens is after you know 10
12 years old we're pretty much running
on autopilot
and we become conditioned or trained
to see the world a certain way to feel
certain things to behave in certain ways
and so most of our life we're working on
autopilot because the non-conscious
processing parts of our brain is working
at you know 400 billion bits of
information per second and trillions of
electrical and chemical reactions per
second happening without our thinking
about it
and so for adults you know 25 35 45 50
we have these patterns that we have to
revamp almost like a remodeling of our
own brains
if you think about you know when you're
driving in a town that you know whether
you're at home or in your city that you
know and all of a sudden you see a
detour
if you take a detour and then you start
driving down that new detour for a day
seven days two weeks three weeks four
weeks that detour becomes the new easy
road to take
even though you're used to going a
certain way
the brain works the exact same way so if
you've got these patterns that are easy
for you your brain wants to take those
patterns that are easy for easy thinking
patterns easy emotional patterns easy
behavioral patterns why
number one because it's
less energy that the brain needs to to
use so law of um best use of energy in
the brain is where it goes first
so the way you retrain your brain
using for example the 4r process is you
recognize my patterns of thought my
patterns of emotion my patterns of
behaviors and yourself are these going
to help me achieve the goal that i want
to achieve whatever the goal is it's
just yes or no
if they are great
if they're not
then what you want to be doing is saying
okay how do i change
that path how do i change my thinking
i'm learning that i could be still i'm
learning that i could be aware of my
thoughts but then let them go and i come
back to focus on a sound wave in this
particular meditation
and then what happens is over a period
of practice you realize that you're
basically your body disappears
you're no longer in this physical thing
you're no longer having these waves of
thought after thought after thought
after thought after thought after idea
positive negative and everything in
between
and in that space of recognizing that
i'm not my physical body i have a
physical body i'm not my thoughts i have
thoughts i'm not my emotions i have them
when you start to train yourself to use
your brain better
more efficiently more productively
you realize that a i am one with this
you know incredible universe so what's
the big deal about that well the big
deal is that if i am one with this
universe with this energy with everyone
and everything
and that's where everything percolates
from
is it possible that all my answers are
right here right now anyway
and the answer is yeah and so meditation
is about practicing and we know that we
have
uh different brain waves so right now as
people are watching or listening you
know they're in this beta brainwave
frequency where their brain is
oscillating at a certain frequency and
there's 50 different brain waves going
on at any given time
but what happens is when i move into
from beta to alpha to theta delta or
gamma i'm actually accessing and
activating different parts of my brain
which now gives me this deeper greater
sense of awareness
of a much bigger you know onion that i'm
used to seeing so i'm living on a layer
of an onion and what if i could see like
10 layers up and 10 layers down so all
of a sudden it's like wow look at who i
am what i am who you are what you are
and in that realization in that
awareness
i can now start to have
different choice
choices made
and so meditation is a practice
of awareness it's a practice of going
internal
instead of external which is where most
people live their lives every day so the
key
is to really understand first and
foremost that you have a brain you're
not your brain the whole idea with inner
size right is to create um a pathway for
you to be able to say okay here's how my
brain works simply as i've put it today
and here's what i could do about it to
move out of a state of chaos and
dissonance and into a state of coherence
and alignment
so when you were born were you born with
any beliefs no were you born with any
habits no were you born with any fears
no no
so from a neuroscience and
neuropsychology perspective a belief is
nothing more than this imagine that
you're born and your brain is made up of
a hundred billion marbles and every time
you have an experience or somebody says
something to you you read something or
you watch something these marbles make
these connections
and the connections that are reinforced
go from conscious connections to
subconscious connections
and once these subconscious connections
are made and reinforced they run the
show 98 of the time
so a belief is nothing more than a
reinforced pattern in the brain
and our conscious brain can choose what
we want when we're in that part of our
brain but our subconscious mind can't
choose its program from the age of zero
to three uh in the imprinting years
three to about seven or eight the
modeling years and then eight on as the
experiential years and so if you have
these uh powerful beliefs that you're
good enough you're smart enough you're
worthy to achieve the goals that you
have um if you have these powerful leads
you are able to achieve any amount of
income you choose no matter what the
amount is you just need to learn how so
if you have these empowering beliefs you
have brain coherence between conscious
and subconscious we're in in a society
that just goes goes goes goes goes goes
goes texts emails phone calls facebook
twitter vine all these things are
keeping us on this perpetual hamster
wheel of doo doo doo doo doo the very
few people stop
and say what am i doing what am i not
doing what am i thinking what am i
feeling so the first part is stop
second part is to reframe
it's called the 4r process recognizes
first
reframe is the way i'm looking at
something
and because we are mono focused the
brain cannot focus consciously on more
than one thing at a time
all right it can get distracted to that
thing then this thing then that thing
then this thing the art of multitasking
is actually one of the worst things that
you can do from a neurological
perspective highly successful people are
able to mono focus on the right things
so when you learn to reframe your
brain's ability to look at this
then look at this
then look at this but stay focused on
what it is that you're looking at you
see different perspectives of it
the next part
is to release
the emotional stress that most people's
brains are under how do we get into this
emotional stress well when we
have fears there's 50 different types of
fears fear success fear of failure fear
of disappointment fear of being
embarrassed fear of being ashamed fear
of being ridiculed fear of fill in the
blank
when our brain goes on these automatic
fear circuit drives
then we're in a state of fight or flight
in a state of fight or flight
over a course of a day a week a month
our
ability to actually use our thinking
center the left prefrontal cortex of our
brain actually diminishes our brain gets
hijacked into this fight or flight
response system over and over and over
and over and over again
and
that response system is actually pretty
healthy initially to get you going and
out of the gate
but if you are always in this fight or
flight response mechanism you're on this
hamster wheel you actually start to get
burnt out and you can't think you can't
use the genius part of your brain you
can't really activate the party that
connects to the entire universe of
intelligence within you and outside of
you and so you learn to release that
tension
to be able to put the foot back on the
gas change the gear if you think about
what happens
when you're driving a stick shift car
you put your foot on the gas in first
gear and the car just goes
but if you keep your foot on the gas in
first gear you're going to burn out the
engine
so what happens in the release part of
using your brain is you go from first
gear pause second gear pause third gear
pause
you're able to use the engine more
efficiently to go faster
exact same thing with our brains if we
learn how to release the tension and
switch gears release the tension switch
gears that's the art of release and go
and that causes the fourth r and that's
we retrain our brain to operate at
higher levels of our intelligence genius
and abilities what happens
if at the subconscious level okay so you
have conscious
goal conscious vision conscious reasons
why i want to achieve it
what happens if at the subconscious
level let's say for weight
you've tried to lose weight before and
maybe you have but then you've gained it
back what if you've done that three or
four or five or six times is that
pattern
okay the memory the pattern
locked in the subconscious mind of all
those experiences
is it there here's how the brain works
you set a goal using the left prefrontal
cortex of your brain your imagination
and then right after you set the goal
and you're excited because you're you're
making some progress
your brain says
hey um last time you did this
uh you gained all the weight back
why even try
uh last time you did this
and your friends saw that you did this
and then you gained all the weight back
next time you saw them you were
embarrassed uh you were a little ashamed
of yourself last time you did this or
the three or four or five or six times
before that um you gained all the weight
back and uh you disappointed yourself
and your significant other because
you know they said you looked really
great and then you gained all the weight
back so you disappointed them uh and
yourself and you're embarrassed or
ashamed um and so
that pattern is there right do you all
agree with me so far the pattern is
there and so if you have and think about
your imagination and your
your your choice to set a goal is one
pattern that you formulate but if
underneath there's a subco
there's a subconscious pattern of
embarrassment shame failure guilt
disappointment etc if that pattern is
also there then you have two opposing
patterns you have one pattern that says
let's go and do this but you have
another pattern that says but last time
you did this you failed or you've seen
your sister or brother or mother or
father or friend do this and guess what
they gained all the weight back anyway
so why even try
i'm going to keep you safe in your
comfort zone i'm going to conserve
energy
and uh that way i'm going to save you
some time and money and energy
does that make sense to you that is
called cognitive dissonance that is
another way of saying that's called
chaos in the brain and a brain in chaos
will do what
it'll just stick around doing the things
that it's comfortable doing where it's
known
something that i learned that i think
people will benefit from is
an anxiety attack stress
uh panic
ulcerative colitis all of these things
are effects
right so they're effects so the question
is what's the cause yes
right so
most people are focusing on either you
know suppressing the effects
depressing the effects um
masking the effects they're doing
everything but going
what's causing this
and if we look at the world of cause
whether it's in our physical body
whether it's our relationship whether
it's our bank account whether it's our
business whatever the result is every
result
in the physical world is an effect
so the question is what causes the
results and one of the greatest laws in
the universe is the law of cause and
effect and it states that for every
effect there's a cause and for every
cause there's an effect
and so i got really inquisitive and
curious early on
with
can i control more of the cause
of my results
and that required responsibility and
when i was younger it was like i was
more into the blame game it's because of
him because of her because of it because
of the market because of where i live
because of my mother my father uh how
old i am or how young i am how asian or
caucasian i am it doesn't make a
difference
so a lot of my upbringing
um caused me to look outside of myself
and when i
looked
inside myself and took the
i guess the
prerequisite of responsibility i own it
yes i can change it
that transformed my life that you know
that really started to to put things
into perspective if you think about
visualization is simulation
now here is the difference whoa that's
good okay go ahead so visualization is
simulation so
when we close our eyes or even if our
eyes are open and we start to use our
einstein brain the imagination
we now have just activated one of the
biggest centers of our brain the
occipital lobe that's connected to the
motor cortex it's connected to the
motivational circuit the nucleus comes
that releases that dopamine that makes
you feel good that makes you want to
take action so if you visualize
yourself achieving the goal if you
visualize yourself behaving in ways that
match the new belief if you even
visualize the words or you take the
words on a sheet of paper
and you read them run your right finger
across it run your left finger across it
close your eyes see it and feel it your
brain is creating a mental movie with
the words and as it creates a mental
movie with the words that's happening in
your subconscious mind
and when you give the subconscious these
instructions a couple things happen
because of the way the brain hierarchy
works number one it's survival but then
number two is safety
and then number three is energy
conservation now when you do something
20 30 40 50 times it takes about 66 days
to
365 days of repetition to override an
old habitual circuit not 10 days not 21
days 66 to 365. so if you visualize
yourself achieving the goal feeling the
success that you want to feel
seeing the belief on the screen of your
mind you are actually creating a neural
network through the science of
neuroplasticity
and the networks that you reinforce
become the most dominant networks and
since your brain wants to conserve
energy
if you do this
on a consistent basis your brain says
okay
you're doing this so often let me just
make this automatic let me set aside the
old beliefs let me replace it with the
new beliefs and now you've deliberately
and consciously evolved yourself one of
the things that is is really interesting
i mean just based on what you said there
is something in business
whether it's for sales people on the
phones or sales people in person on the
phone it's called call reluctance
and in person it's po it's called
contact reluctance and so if you think
about what does that mean so i have a
call reluctance i have a reluctance to
call somebody that i don't know
and so when some people think about
calling somebody they don't know when
they're prospecting or meeting somebody
they don't know
if you think about what is it that is
actually happening that causes them to
to feel that so as soon as they have the
thought
their neurochemistry kicks in because
the meaning that they have is if i call
somebody
that i don't know and they hang up on me
they yell at me
they
say something nasty to me
then they are attacking my identity and
in most cases they have associated
the attack on their identity in a
negative way
such as well maybe it's true that i'm
not good enough maybe it's true that i'm
not smart enough maybe it's true that
i'm not worthy
so they have a negative association with
somebody's response that they don't even
know
about who they are
so the first thing we work on is let's
focus on your self-esteem
because it's the self-esteem that's
being attacked my self-esteem and
self-worth is being attacked so when my
self-esteem and self-worth is being
attacked in a negative way or unpleasant
way i'm going to process that as danger
in my brain
now when you understand the brain's
number one responsibility is to move you
away from danger or pain that's number
one on its hierarchy of how it behaves
so if there is real or imagined pain or
discomfort your brain says stop put the
brakes on go the other way that's what's
happening
so the first thing we do is we teach
people number one let's change the
meaning that you have around what
somebody else's response is
around who you are or what you're doing
or what you're offering them so the
first thing we work on is change the
meaning you change the feeling for the
people who think that the law of
attraction is
um you know think believe and you'll
achieve first i'm going to tell you that
so let's call it
um but i want you to think of your brain
just a little bit differently and think
of it this way let's say you love rock
and roll
and let's say rock and roll is on
station
95.5
if you're on station 92.1 that might be
classical
if you're on station 98.7 that might be
punk rock but at 92.5
that's rock and roll
so imagine coherence just means locking
your electromagnetic
spectrum of your brain lock it and load
it on exactly what you want so what's
the vision what's the goal what are the
beliefs what are the emotions that
create coherence so you're locked and
loaded to the frequency of the universe
that is matching that goal part one part
two is when you get locked and loaded
you've actually activated the einstein
brain connected to the motor cortex
connected to the dopamine release in
your body
and when that happens
okay now you're in coherence but there's
another part that happens in this
einstein part of the brain that's
actually what the latest neuroscientists
psychologists are thinking is connected
to this gps part of our brain to the
frequency of where all of the tools
resources people are that resonate with
that
frequency so
we've been evolving for what two and a
half million years since homo erectus to
now 108 billion humans on earth with a
brain that's been changing and growing
and my belief is we're just scratching
the proverbial surface we talk about you
know little quantum mechanics or
quantifies with entanglement how we're
all connected we're all tuning into the
frequencies that are us and within us
and all around us
now when we learn to use our brain
better uh it's just mind-boggling how we
can achieve goals and dreams that we
thought were impossible to achieve
before this is the fun part now a lot of
people ask me about money all the time
it's one of the things we teach people
how to do is grow their businesses and
how to make more money
and they say well you know i want to
make more money
i said well in order to make more money
first you have to believe that you can
right then you have to believe you
deserve it
then you have to make sure that you have
something that you can earn money with
so it's either going to be
your ideas you want to you can sell your
ideas
yeah like a trainer
you can sell your time you can sell your
product you can sell your services which
means that you have to have some skill
or you have to have somebody else who
could do it for you
you have to see your skill right
well you have to either see your skill
or determine what skills are needed okay
and if you don't have it get somebody
else who has it to help you
and so
when when somebody tells me i want to
make more money i say them let's say we
have a pen i don't have a pen here but
if we had a pen
yes and we wanted to make money
we could go and find somebody who wants
to buy this pen
right now
and how much is somebody willing to pay
for the pen
well if the pen is worth a dollar
maybe you can get a dollar for it but
what about finding somebody who needs it
because they have to sign a contract
that's due in 10 minutes
that person might pay a hundred dollars
for that pin
yeah
so our job
is to take you know our skills our
knowledge our products our services our
abilities
and to be able to present it to people
who need it and want it
in exchange for money i think feeling
and knowing that you've
used your life in a way
that makes yourself proud that you're
proud of you you felt like what a
journey
and i left it all out on the field and i
just left it all in the field that's
my own greatness you know knowing that i
used my life in a way that i left it all
out on the field that the the bruises
the bangs you know the trials the
tribulations the highs the lows that you
used it as soon as you blame
shame or justify
you are disempowering yourself instead
of
being responsible
for your emotions your feelings your
attitude and your actions
when you take responsibility
then you are not at the mercy of the
outside world and what happens in the
outside world
you
learn
how to upgrade your emotional ability so
whether you are happy or sad or
disgusted or frustrated or angry or
fearful you know how to navigate the
emotions that causes either the
motivational center in your brain to
light up
or the fear center in your brain to
light up thereby causing you to stop and
procrastinate and not take action
everybody can be an entrepreneur but
i don't want anybody to go and be an
entrepreneur who's got a lot of passion
you know for a product or a service or
something that they love
without realizing
that there are many hats that you have
to wear
right there's the person who has to know
all the little details there's the
person who has to have the vision
there's the person who has to manage
there's a person who has to create the
strategies the tactics of what to do
then there's the person has to drive
those forward those are six different
things that have to be done just
different hats in a business
that most entrepreneurs aren't aware of
yeah and so they they start and they're
busy and they're working really hard
they go god this is hard
yeah and it is hard
and they think that they have to do it
all themselves
and
that's not the
that's not the truth
yeah you have to learn to delegate right
yeah well you can delegate you can
partner with people you can
barter with people there's a variety of
different ways to do it but first you
have to know what you don't know
it's not easy well it's not easy if
you're the one trying to figure it out
but if you talk to somebody or hire
somebody who's an expert
they'll tell you in seconds
so you know when you came over here you
know you're setting up all your cameras
and your lights and all that stuff you
did that in 15 minutes if i was to that
would take me 15 days
because you're playing at this yeah
you've done 150 interviews now right yes
and so so you already know you've
learned 150 you know uh times and the
setup and takedown and mistakes and what
to do right what to do wrong what you
need to have backups for what to do for
editing for lighting for daytime for
night time for clouds if the voice works
if the sound there's hundreds of things
you have to learn just for this
yeah oh and you have to be an excellent
interviewer too
right
yes yeah so there's so many things that
you didn't know when you first started
this yeah that now you know
so imagine if i wanted to
do what you do
yeah i could say well you know what i'm
going to do this i'm going to go and
figure out which cameras to buy and
which lighting to buy and how many
batteries do i need how many wires do i
need and how many plugs do i need for
the walls and how many backup systems do
i need i could try to figure all that
out
or i could say to you
can you do me a favor yeah can you give
me a list
of what to do what not to do what to buy
what not to buy how much it should be
where i should buy it you could say yeah
i could do that in one or two hours yeah
i could save months if not a year of my
time time and money and everything right
and so i much prefer
to find the specialized knowledge
and pay for that
and just apply it if you don't
understand that every brain has an error
detection mechanism within it okay what
is that
any time
you
veer out of your comfort zone the fat
point setting or the financials anytime
you veer out of it the first line of
defense is self-talk that's negative
that's the first thing that pops up
because your brain is going that's not
true so it's detecting an error between
what you said as an affirmation even
what you just visualized or even what
you just did
against the predominant neural patterns
that exist
so it's an 800 pound gorilla initially
fighting the flea right
dan heath's book
and so what we want to do is we want to
get the the conscious goal the vision
aligned with the non-conscious pattern
and as soon as you align that you have
neural coherence and when you have
neural coherence that's like hearing
your most favorite band
playing your favorite song and you're
just like
oh that's the best
yeah it's just bliss
if it's not bliss you're out of
coherence
and so the key and why we start off
early with meditation is awareness of
how do i tune in my vibration how do i
let go of that unempowered self-talk
that sentence that thought that i had or
that disempowering it's an unpleasant
feeling beliefs aren't good or bad
they're only pleasant to unpleasant at
varying degrees
when we're at a coherence it's
unpleasant unless our
life is on the line and safety is there
for the most part you know a fear of
failing
where is that coming from we failed our
whole lives successfully
but the meaning that we're giving you
know uh what people will say what people
think you know how i'll be embarrassed
or ashamed those are all the things that
you need to really get in tune with
i have a philosophy that
every moment every precious nanosecond
and moment is perfect
and so when i connect to the perfection
of that moment
there's really nothing to do it's to be
aware and to allow to surrender but not
to give up surrender but to understand
that you know as you know we are talking
right now
uh
the oceans don't need any instruction
what to do the uh the um planets that
are moving in in their elliptical orbits
around the sun don't need yours or my
intervention the universe the milky way
galaxy that's you know flowing through
the universe at a million and a half
miles per hour doesn't need yours and my
instruction
so that means that every moment is
perfect so i want to connect to the
perfection of every single moment be
aware of that every single moment and
realize that many things are not to my
taste many things i don't understand
but that doesn't mean that the moment
isn't perfect every human being has a
relationship with money and money is
something that um
envelops people's brains about what they
buy what they don't buy whether they buy
you know a business class or first class
or uh regular economy seats whether
they're always looking for the cheapest
or the most expensive the nicest uh or
uh average how much they will tip how
much they want we all have
a money story that we've developed
mostly from our parents
and the people that
we live near and we developed this
relationship around money and our
beliefs around money you know are we
good enough to earn that amount uh are
we worthy enough to earn that amount um
uh is it is it um worth it or not and so
one of the things that mary morrissey
um says that um we should do she says
for seven days
write down the thoughts you have about
money and notice when you're thinking
um and notice what you are thinking and
notice that the money story you're
telling yourself is it positive negative
is it abundance thinking or limited
thinking is it scarcity thinking or is
it
what fill in the blank and so once you
know your money story and this is also
something that one of our um
psychiatrists who works with us dr david
kruger says once you know the story the
money story
that's when you can start to be aware of
it and go wow where did i get these
limiting beliefs about money about my
value where do i get these limiting
beliefs of what i can afford what i
can't where do i get these limiting
beliefs
around um
how i behave with money let's say you
have a car which i imagine most people
who are watching have a car
imagine you're driving your car
and a light comes on the dash
it's like oh i wonder what that light is
and you look a little bit closer and it
says there's a little you're low on oil
in the engine okay so you're aware of
that and the light stays on and then two
seconds later another light comes on hey
what's going on and it says that uh the
rear tire is low on air
you know god what the hell is going on
and so you keep driving you say at the
next gas station i'm going to stop and
i'll fill up the air and um i'll put
some oil in the um in the engine so that
i top everything up now why am i using
that example when we have an emotion
all emotions everybody pay close
attention
you have emotions you are not your
emotions emotions are different than
feelings
emotions happen as a autumn as an
automatic
subconscious trigger
when your brain is evaluating something
you want to do or something that you are
doing against the memory that's in there
that's causing this old emotion of how
you felt or what you did or what you
were thinking or what you were
experiencing at the time that the memory
was created so all emotions are
processed at the subconscious level and
whatever pattern is associated with that
behavior that you're doing right now or
the incoming stimuli from the outside
world is going to trigger this emotion
which then sends a neurochemical release
that you feel as guilt and has the
thought patterns of guilt or the
emotions of being embarrassed
the feeling is the conscious awareness
of the cocktail of neurochemicals that
have been released but the emotion is
subconscious so
is it possible
to recalibrate
a neurological pattern in the brain is
it possible if a pattern is nothing more
than neurons that have been coalesced or
connected
can you interrupt a pattern from the
past
is it possible to interrupt a pattern
from the past
so answer that question is it possible
to interrupt a pattern from the past
right so is it possible
is it possible
of course it's possible
any pattern that exists in the brain is
nothing more than a group of neurons
brain cells that in many cases have 10
000 connections okay at the end of each
neuron that formulate this connectedness
between the neurons so you can interrupt
a pattern just like you can interrupt
and create a new habit you can interrupt
an emotional pattern a behavioral
pattern
a feeling pattern and you can interrupt
it using a variety of methodologies you
can take a pattern and you can visualize
it getting smaller you can accentuate it
with colors with uh animal
images with visualization with
meditation with mindfulness with
affirmations with subliminal programming
you can interrupt patterns and even more
important than that based on the latest
research on neuroplasticity you can
create a new pattern
and that becomes the new default pattern
the parts of the brain that register
and experience
versus the part of the brain that can
imagine an experience are not different
so if i imagine doing a bicep curl in my
mind i see my arm moving and i'm doing a
bicep curl in my mind i'm accessing the
occipital lobe part of my brain it is no
different
than me going to the gym and doing a
bicep curl
so when you do both
you solidify the experience even more
now i want to just talk about what you
just said about your partner who brings
in meditation
when most people
are asked to do something that they're
fearful of
the sympathetic nervous system in the
brain kicks in in nanoseconds not in
minutes in nanoseconds that's the fight
or flight response system in the brain
so they want to run away or they freeze
and they can't do anything
but if you take that same experience
that you want them to do
and you have them do it in their mind
first in a calm state so first if you
have them visualize
doing that and they feel nervous but you
just have to do one little thing
six breaths
why six breaths we know from the
research now that if you imagine in your
mind doing something that you're fearful
of
and you allow the parasympathetic
nervous system to rule
that means that you're going to be
shallow breathing you're going to raise
your blood pressure you're going to
activate your sweat glands and you're
going to activate all of the fight or
fear
response mechanism the fight or flight
response mechanisms and that is a very
tense
situation to be in
what if you could take somebody and have
them imagine that exact same thing but
before they take the action they see
themselves they just take 60 breaths one
see yourself doing it two three
four five six what happens is because
you're breathing deeply in and out
your parasympathetic nervous system okay
kicks in why because that is the relaxed
response mechanism in the brain so if
you
consciously activate your relaxation
response mechanism
with something that would normally be
stressful for you you actually
deactivate the fear center in the brain
the amygdala and you actually open up
your thinking center of your brain the
genius part of your brain that can
actually
override the fear center of the brain
it's a small little mechanism that you
can just learn how to do so i say you do
both
not one or
learn both
goes back to upgrade your knowledge and
skills of saying why am i afraid which
system of mine you know is operating
right now so think about this when we
walk into a room
we could flip the switch and turn on the
light because we want more light well
why not flip your own genius switch why
not flip off the switch of fear and
anxiety and stress
and flip on the switch of calmness
certainty and creativity
there it's your switch
we just haven't been taught how to turn
one switch off and turn one switch on
what if
you said okay i want to make let's just
say a hundred thousand dollars a year or
a million it doesn't make a difference
and i asked you
what do you need to believe about
yourself
to achieve this so i need to believe i'm
smart enough good write down i am smart
enough what else do you need to believe
i need to believe that i am worthy i
need to believe that i deserve this i
need to believe that it's possible i
need to leave you write down five or six
or seven beliefs that are just words on
a sheet of paper now let me stop for
just a moment i'm going to tell a story
and come back to this i want you to
imagine
that somebody tapped you
on the shoulder sometime today and say
hey
i work with steven spielberg and tom
hanks in hollywood and we have this new
script okay that if you get really good
at this script where you could read it
in front of a camera without the script
we'll pay you 10 million bucks
now i want you to imagine you've never
seen the script you don't know how to
act but they said to you we're going to
give you an acting coach we're going to
give you everything you need to memorize
the script we're giving you everything
you need to act it perfectly what would
you do
to take that script that's on a piece of
paper that you've never seen before what
would you do to take that script
to make it yours for you to own it and
the answer is you probably read it like
what once
uh would you read it maybe 100 times 200
times 500 times you think you might
role play with somebody while you're
holding the script in your hand do you
think you might research the role do you
think you might take a camera and
practice it and you think that if you
practice it one time 50 times 100 times
500 times you can finally put the script
down and you can get in front of the
camera and go boom here is the script do
you think you could do that well guess
what a script that's on a piece of paper
that you don't believe with practice you
start to believe so what happens if you
take a belief system and you start to
imprint it into your subconscious mind
initially through conscious repetition
but there are ways to access the
subconscious mind that we know today
that are faster and easier than just
doing it consciously and so you take a
vision of you achieving your goals and
dreams you take the beliefs you need you
learn how to manage your emotions a
little bit better and then you develop
the habits which again are nothing more
than neural patterns in the brain have
been reinforced when you learn how to
deactivate the destructive ones and
activate constructive ones
through space repetition and
reinforcement now you are resetting your
default way of being
so a belief is nothing more than a
reinforced pattern that if you learn how
to deactivate it and create a new one
it's like a software upgrade for your
brain all we have which everybody talks
about is this this moment this this
precious second right now so the more i
could be here right now
um
the more i'm living you know
the life that i want to live
i don't want to be focusing too much
about the future too much about the past
i can use those as something to you know
hope for in the future as a guiding post
from the past um but right now is the
moment that every one of us has so if
you take
any event that's occurred in the past if
you just merely think of that event
that's occurred in the past chances are
you're firing off the neural network of
that pattern
right so you can take um
the idea of eating your favorite dessert
what do you think is happening in your
brain when you pretend you're eating
that favorite dessert of yours and your
mouth starts to water and you start to
feel oh that's such a great dessert
that's neurons in your brain firing in
the neurochemistry that is associated
with that memory firing now
let's say
that you have a
disempowering pattern of being
embarrassed or ashamed or ridiculed but
instead of just thinking about the
pattern oh i don't like it as soon as
you think about the pattern
and it has a i'm going to say a
disempowering or negative emotion
chances are that means that the stress
center in the brain has been activated
that means that your heartbeat is going
to go up that means that your sweat
glands are going to be activated that
means you're going to breathe a little
bit less uh
deeply you're going to be more shallowly
and that is the fear or stress response
now what if
instead of allowing that to continue
you just stopped
and you had this intention
i'm going to dissolve
the effectiveness or the strength of
this pattern how do you do that well
first and foremost you stop you sit
and you start with inner size number one
that actually i guide you through
in the book all right and inner size
number one
is
called take six calm the circuits so you
want to move from your stress and react
system
to your relax and respond system you
have
parasympathetic and sympathetic nervous
systems okay that are triggered within
the body so what happens when you sit
quietly and you take six deep breaths in
through your nose
and out through your mouth like you're
blowing out through a straw when you do
it six times in 10 second rhythmic
breaths
and you focus
on the air that you're blowing out
through your mouth like you're blowing
out through a straw
that simple inner size
is inner size number one take six calm
the circuits it actually
deactivates the stress fear
embarrassment shame guilt circuit
and in a quiet relaxed state
that same memory does not have the same
power
but if you don't do it in that state you
do it in a in a tense stressful state
you're actually reinforcing that pattern
versus thinking about bringing up that
old memory
and doing this repetitively
10 times 20 times 30 times 40 times
until the neurons really don't fire that
strength at that strength level the
stuff that i'm fascinated with is
behavior right perception and behavior
is how i see myself
and how people see themselves
and why and then how they see the world
and why and then
we know that
the action i mean you know in the secret
you mentioned earlier i was in the
secret and the thing i loved about the
secret is gave people some hope that
changing my thinking really can make a
difference but there's also the other
part of it you know the law of
attraction there was one thing that was
left down it was called the law of goya
and the law of [ __ ] is the g-o-y-a law
it's a get off your ass law
there is nobody that i know other than
trust fund friends okay that haven't had
to do any work to achieve their success
nobody that i know whether it's tony
shea whether it's you whether it's me
whether it's mark cuban whether it
doesn't mean richard branson oprah
winfrey doesn't make a difference
they've all had to take actions but it's
not just any action it's taking the
right actions in the right order at the
right time consistently
and so i've been fascinated with how do
we help people develop the mental
emotional and behavioral
habits
that lead to success because that's the
key mindset skill set and action set
that's the formula let's say
you have
a shortage of money right now
let's say you're not
earning as much as you'd like and
there's too much month left at the end
of the money too much month left at the
end of money creates stress
decisions around money can create stress
what to buy what not to buy is it too
expensive is it you know not expensive
enough for my taste whatever the
the the the stress is um i want you to
understand stress a little bit
differently from the from the brain
perspective this is the um
part of the brain the the brain stem
that is attached to the first part of
being called the reptilian brain which
is connected very very quickly to the
amygdala the stress response center in
the brain
when we have stress in our life whether
it's money stress emotional stress
relationship stress business stress
career stress whatever stress we have
the signal that is sent through
the electrical system in the brain and
the chemical system in the brain when
stress is activated
there's a part of the brain called the
vagus nerve and the sympathetic nervous
system which is part of your autonomic
nervous system but the sympathetic
nervous system
specifically is the system that
activates a stress response system
activates one of four things
fear
okay
um and when and we'll talk about fear in
just a moment but when we're in a state
of stress the fight or flight response
kicks in the sympathetic nervous system
so when we're in a fight
mindset
we are we are using a lot of epinephrine
adrenaline cortisol and there's this
current of anxiety
now that's not that bad if it's a little
bit but when it's too much it actually
deactivates the thinking part of your
brain that can actually solve the reason
you're stressed so when we are in this
fight or flight which is runaway
modality or the freeze or faint modal
there are people who freeze when they're
under too much stress there are people
who faint under too much stress there
are people
um who who run away and there's people
just try to fight it so
when we are looking at the brain
and we're looking at stress okay this is
what heidi's talking about here she says
stress is our own gps system saying that
something
is out of alignment
uh and the energy movement from the
common respond part of the brain is gone
to the stress and react part of the
brain and so
one of the the tools to calm the brain
down to go from reactive stress
to relax and respond
is inner size number one that we teach
and that you're all going to be able to
uh
learn in my new book
called inner size but inner size number
one is called take six calm the circuits
so whenever you're feeling stressed
whenever there's a problem whenever
you're feeling overwhelmed whenever
you're feeling confused whenever you're
feeling like it's too much stop
as opposed to trying to fight your way
through it stop calm down
close your eyes
take six deep breaths like this
in through your nose gently in a rhythm
of about um six breaths
per minute every 10 seconds
and when
you do a breathing exercise take six
calm the circuits that's inner size
number one you actually deactivate the
stress response center in the brain and
you activate the calm
and respond part of the brain highly
successful people
whether they're taught it like we teach
it or they just know how to do it
automatically they do it they feel fear
and then they release that fear and they
take action anyway
so they can turn their fear into fuel is
one of the things that we teach people
how to do turn your fear into your fuel
and when you turn your fear into your
fuel in a calm centered way
you now are able to use that
neuroelectrical chemical called
epinephrine
or cortisol the stress
hormones and use them to fuel your
success
faster and easier than ever before you
just reminded me of something
something that i learned that i think
people will benefit from is
an anxiety attack stress uh panic
ulcerative colitis all of these things
are effects
right so they're effects so the question
is what's the cause yes
right so
most people are focusing on either you
know suppressing the effects um
depressing the effects um uh masking the
effects they're doing everything but
going
what's causing this
and if we look at the world of cause
whether it's in our physical body
whether it's our relationship whether
it's our bank account whether it's our
business whatever the result is every
result
in the physical world is an effect
so the question is what causes the
results
and one of the greatest laws in the
universe is the law of cause and effect
and it states that for every effect
there's a cause and for every cause
there's an effect i often say that
there's only four things that are
holding you back as a human being only
four there's not 25 there's four
that are the core one is if your vision
and goal
is bigger than yourself image
okay so if you feel you deserve it you
can have this vision and goal and be
excited about and motivate about it you
will not do what it takes to achieve one
two if you have limiting beliefs if you
have a vision and goal but you have a
limited belief that you're too young too
old whatever the case is your limiting
beliefs will drive your behavior three
fear fear of being embarrassed ashamed
ridiculed or judged fear of failure fear
of disappointment and we'll talk about
disappointing moment or fear of
succeeding and
failing again disappointment
most and then the fourth one by the way
is you're lacking the knowledge and
skill required so that actually sets up
a self-doubt trigger which activates the
frankenstein brain which causes you to
lose motivation but most people prefer
to master disappointment and comfort
zones
instead of mastering change
so if i master disappointment i know
what i got
i just have to deal with well okay this
is what i got and if i master my comfort
zone then at least this is the devil i
know
yes
versus mastering change and we know
what's going on in our brain under we
know what's happening neurologically
biologically emotionally physically and
all of that is a skill
it's just a skill
so
why not just master change why not
become an adaptationist right now in the
time that you need it the most in the
world
uh because if you don't then you're just
going to keep repeating the same
patterns that are going gonna get
reinforced and it makes it harder in
three months six months in six years so
master change now
and make that one of your core
competencies
and then you master your life and so if
we think about what is a limiting belief
like from a neuroscience perspective
when a neuroanatomist looks in your
brain right they can't see oh here's the
limiting belief pattern between here and
here
but we do know that a limiting belief is
nothing more than a neural network a
pattern in the brain the marbles
connected
right and if they've connected and have
been reinforced
often enough and strongly enough they
become part of something known as the
default mode network we just default to
that belief why because we have enough
references to say this is true this
limiting belief that i'm not good enough
i'm not smart enough i'm too young i'm
too old i'm too asian or caucasian
somehow we have information and
experiences that says this is real
so we're operating from that
automatically we're operating from that
automatically but what does that really
mean what it means is not only does it
affect what we do or don't do
but it affects the lens by which we're
seeing the world we only see the world
through
the lens of our empowering beliefs or
disempowering beliefs
so imagine if you had a lens whether
it's on your camera or on your glasses
and all of a sudden you put a coating on
it to take out all the blue light
you're not going to see the world the
same yep all the blue light is gone well
limiting beliefs or empowering positive
beliefs do the exact same thing
if you
think about a radio and a radio is a
good example if you were on
98.5
let's say there's rock and roll on that
station at 98.8
there might be
classical music at
99.1 there might be
big band okay music so i do agree that
when you get aligned mentally and tune
in to what it is that you want
you're in resonance with that energy
field and there's millions of
frequencies okay all around us
so the first thing
is yes
get totally cleared get totally on the
station of what you want to achieve
that's step one
if you're here and there and here and
there then you're on a variety of
different stations and i totally believe
that our brain emits a frequency based
on our predominant
thoughts
and emotions and it also is in a
receptive state
when you're practicing certain spiritual
practices or you're on that frequency
and you're on that channel so i do
believe in that that's called being in a
resonance
but i do not believe for one second that
while we're sitting here
in this hotel room okay at the encore
hotel
somebody's gonna knock on the door and
say
john
nick
you guys just want a billion dollars
because we are in residence no we we
have to participate
in the process and do something to help
create that we have 100 trillion cells
in our body
i've had neck injuries shoulder injuries
meniscus injuries i've had ankle
injuries i've had i've had injuries
because i've always been pretty athletic
if you think about what is happening
every time i breathe in
i'm breathing in hydrogen oxygen
nitrogen carbon plus a whole bunch of
other elements from the air
um what do you think your bones and
tissues and muscles are made of i'm
eating you know let's say i'm eating a
protein whether it's tofu or a piece of
chicken right i'm eating a protein that
is making muscle um eating fat i'm
drinking water uh we are made up of
hydrogen oxide nitrogen and carbon
mostly and so
every seven years we're making a whole
new body our eyeballs are different our
skeleton is different our brain is not
the same cells that were in our brain
seven years ago our lungs liver heart
tissues nothing is the same
and so if i am
visualizing if i am meditating if i am
seeing a new healed
bone if i'm seeing a new healed
part of my being um is it possible that
i can direct
some of what's happening in my body and
the answer is of course i can there are
so many people that have healed
okay from traumatic brain injuries from
back injuries from um from tears and all
that stuff and so i absolutely believe
that we can heal so that is that is my
opinion and we're we're just starting to
scratch the proverbial surface of what
our potential really is and it starts
with our brain and so the research that
that our neuroscientists
and neuropsychologists provide us with
is what drives behavior what are
emotions what are feelings what are the
six core emotions that are processed at
the non-conscious level that give rise
to feeling
see
feeling is conscious awareness of what
i'm experiencing in my body
the emotion of anger disgust shame
happiness or fear is processed
non-consciously
that gives
what an electrical signal that we feel
that's called feelings and so what we're
fascinated with is
how are people processing information
that gives rise to feelings which then
causes people to take action or not
so that's the kind of stuff i'm
fascinated with and then how can we help
somebody shift their perspective if you
change the way you look at something
the feeling changes
so if you change the meaning you change
the way you look at something the
feeling change if the feeling changes
and we help people put their foot on the
gas instead of on the brake
then they're going to take action and
most people i mean if everybody's
watching right now they're thinking why
am i not doing forget about learning
anything new why am i not doing the
things i already know i should be doing
so a salesperson you mentioned earlier
you know they know they should be
prospecting why aren't they prospecting
more
like why not
well it's because something in their
brain
has got the brake on
why not discover why
get your foot off the brake take action
so you may or may not know this story
yet but uh 10 years ago i was 238 pounds
33 body fat borderline hypertensive diet
almost full on diabetes severe sleep
apnea
not in good shape
and so i said listen you've done okay in
business you've done okay with your
relationship you're happily married
great this and that um look at you
you're you're a physical mess
and so
words are really really really critical
because there's something really
important listening and so if you're
using words that you're reinforcing if
they're self-deprecating words you're
reinforcing a self-deprecating
self-image which means frankenstein
brain's going to be triggered by those
words so if you think about
weight what is it every pound is 3 500
calories of energy
right and so when you think about what
do you do when you lose something what
have we been taught to do when we lose
something try and find it go find it go
get it back
so if
if weight is energy
i said to myself what do i need to do to
release this energy
back into the universe back in the form
of hydrogen oxide nitrogen carbon
whatever it is
so that somebody else who needs it right
now can use it it served me long enough
i'm ready to release it and to change
you know my physique to change how i
feel to change how i look and my goal
back then for my 50th birthday was to
get into the best shape of my adult life
for 50 which i did and then my goal is
to have a six pack at 60 which i'm
already there
so i'm actually almost there but the
whole idea was the words that i use
right are really important because
they're the words that i listen to and
reinforce when we talk about the word
fear right so let me let me start off
with another you know little premise
here is um
most people are highly ignorant
in understanding what fear is
now i want to make sure people heard me
correctly ignorance doesn't mean you are
stupid
ignorance means you just don't know
we're all ignorant we don't know what we
don't know well we don't know we don't
know and even the things that we do know
may not be accurate
so when we talk about fear there are 50
different types of fear
all fear all fear
is processed in the subconscious mind
the
automatic
neurochemistry that is created as a
result of the meaning that we give
certain things that cause us to either
be in a state or of fear or a stage of a
state of
courageousness
is all being processed in our
subconscious mind
so what causes fear for you
doesn't cause fear for me or for
somebody else or may cause fear in other
people so whether you know we're
standing at the you know top of a
building that's 100 stories high some
people look over and don't have fear and
other people do have fear
whether there's a giant 10 foot boa
constrictor you know in front of you may
cause fear in you that doesn't cost fear
in another person so
it's never the thing
that is causing the fear it's the
subconscious interpretation that we've
been conditioned
to believe the meaning that we learn to
give something determines whether the
neurochemistry of fear is activated that
causes us to feel a certain way so the
feeling
okay of
of being scared the feeling of being
uncertain this feeling of having
self-doubt the feeling of uh um
of having too much uh stress in our life
that is an effect
not a cause so feelings are conscious
our ability to be aware of this stuff
that's going on in our body that we
either know or don't know how to handle
or do anything with yeah so feeling is
conscious fear is subconscious and so if
for example
we have um you know
one of the examples i use is uh and you
don't have this obviously but if i ask a
hundred people you know
do you have a fear of public speaking i
was just going to say that we're so
excited i was just going to say that i'm
reading your mind i'm reading your mind
well it's not your fear and that's what
i'm going to say so
the actual fear
is of being embarrassed ashamed
ridiculed or judged
so if we're afraid of being
embarrassed ashamed ridiculed or judged
that has nothing to do with the actual
public speaking it has to do with our
self-image and self-esteem and what we
think of ourselves and what we believe
others will say or think about us which
will affect our own self-image or
self-esteem let's say
you have
something that you want to do a project
you want to finish a book you want to
write a business you want to start uh a
girl you want to call or walk across the
room or a guy um you want to achieve a
goal
okay so if you imagine that when you set
your goal you're activating the left
prefrontal cortex which i like to call
is the einstein part of the brain the
part of your brain that can say what can
i imagine well i can imagine myself
achieving that goal i can imagine myself
making more money and living the
lifestyle of my dreams i can imagine
fill in the blank
so you set the goal so part one in the
brain is setting of the goal having that
vision for what you want we know uh up
until about 20 years ago
scientists believed that we were
hardwired so we were born uh we had
certain genetic propensities you're like
your mother like your father like your
grandparents and then you became a
little bit like you as a combination of
both those and your experiences
well the science was wrong right we just
have learned a lot more in the last 20
years than we've known in the last 480
since we began science
and so the science of neuroplasticity
shows us that we're consistently
creating new connections
uh but but to
leave it at that is is not very useful
so the question is like so what right so
what's a new connection like what's the
big deal and think about this
um what baby was ever born with
any beliefs
nothing what born what baby was born
with any habits
what baby was born with any prejudices
um at all or racist you know ideas none
what baby was born with any perspectives
or paradigms or have no no no no none
and so what happens is a baby is born
with about a hundred billion cells so i
think about 100 billion cells like you
would 100 billion marbles
and every time the marbles yes a lot of
marbles right that's why you lose your
marbles so so every time the baby heard
something saw something felt something
experienced something these marbles made
connections in their in their brain
and that's called neuroplasticity the
brain's ability to create new
connections
and it's doing that every second of
every day
and by the time we're you know three
four years old we've gotten a lot of
these neural connections these beliefs
and habits and perspectives from our
caregivers our parents our brothers or
sisters how they treat us how we feel as
we develop these connections you know
from zero to three four the imprinting
years you know and then we have the
modeling years where we're modeling our
parents from you know two and a half
three to five six seven where we're
dressing like them and trying to put on
their makeup
which i did too
and so we're modeling now and then we
have our experiential years where we
gain some of our own experiences and we
are creating these new connections in
our brain
that become our map of the world here's
how the world works you know uh white
people are this black people are that
when i when i put my finger in this
socket it feels really bad so don't do
it more than once you know when i eat
this i like it and you know when i see
this i laugh and and when i do this it
hurts and so we develop this model of
the world and we develop our beliefs
about money about relationships about
career about travel about food we
develop all of this stuff
um you know by the millions and millions
and millions of connections every hour
and then slows down after we're about 10
or 12 years old so we have this map this
road map of reality
and based on our parents and caregivers
and grandparents and teachers and
television and whatever we experienced
some of that map is accurate
and some of that map is not some of
those beliefs are accurate some of them
are not some of the habits we developed
are constructive and some are
destructive
right but from a neuroscience
perspective they're nothing more than
just connections between one marble or
another
now here's the good news great news
actually we can deliberately create our
own connections now because we know that
this science of neuroplasticity
says that if we take let's say an
affirmation i'm so happy and grateful
that i am more and more confident each
and every day
so it may not sound real initially when
you say that but that's because you've
said it one time and the connection is
weak
but if you said that a hundred times or
500 times or a thousand times and then
you felt it and then you went out and
did a couple of little things to give
you some confidence let's say you're shy
and you just went to um i don't know a
coffee shop and you just smiled at
somebody and nodded to them didn't have
cereal just smiled and nude and they
smiled and nodded back and go oh wow
that didn't hurt they didn't hurt me
they didn't say anything bad about me
they didn't embarrass me they didn't try
to shame me they didn't try to make me
feel guilty
and if you did that enough
for a day a week a month three months
all of a sudden you'd be
inner sizing
your self-confidence muscle
and shyness starts to go away a little
bit at first
and then it's like wow this isn't a
dangerous place have you ever considered
that imagination
um creativity
logic uh focus
um concentration self-esteem self-worth
tenacity resolve have you ever
considered
that those are
neuro muscles
we have biceps triceps shoulders
chest
buttocks
muscles for your physical body have you
ever considered
that you have
neuro muscles
have you ever considered that creativity
is a neuro
muscle that you can
utilize you know one of the first things
that i learned at a
enough a young age through my mentors
was failure is just feedback and
separate
you
as a human being from what you've tried
that fails so don't connect if you fail
at things that there's something wrong
with you
so i was fortunate that you know i've
failed and i've always failed forward
and i said what's the lesson what did i
learn
and it just made me better so i've had
you know a lot of great
great opportunities for learning one of
the things that people are whoops
making a big big mistake on
is they
are trying to master a lot of channels
like i do right now
when
they should be mastering one channel
first
so should you
master
facebook
and creating a little tribe in
communities should you master
advertising on facebook
should you
master youtube because you enjoy videos
like i do and creating videos is easy
for you and you can talk about your
product your service your knowledge your
skills that people want to understand
because the people who watch youtube
is a very different profile than the
person who watches or is on facebook and
in many cases the people that are on
facebook aren't paying attention to
instagram
right
so
you have to master one thing first based
on your knowledge your skills and your
abilities and your budget
right so when i go live and do a session
here you know i have a team that's
behind me i've got people that can
manage the controls like if i had to
manage all the controls and go live on
all these chat
channels that would be difficult for me
but speaking and then getting onto all
the channels that's easy so which is
the channel that you are going to get
really good at because there's millions
of people prospects who could want your
product or service
and if you're trying to be everything to
everyone on all the challenge channels
chances are you're going to diffuse your
energy instead of focus your energy so
let me give you an example
sunlight
right so if
you are outside and it's sunny
you can get a nice little tan right
but if you take a magnifying glass hold
on look
where's my magnifying glass
i have one here somewhere if you take a
magnifying glass
you can take the sunlight and you can
take a piece of paper
right and you can magnify that same
energy and burn a hole in the paper you
can take that same sunlight and reduce
it to single photons and you can cut
through a laser so instead of doing a
little bit here and a little bit there
and a little bit there and a little bit
there
why not master if you have limiting
beliefs like you're not good enough not
worthy enough you don't have enough
money knowledge skills you're too young
you're too old
neural patterns in your brain is what
beliefs are
and we have constructive ones
destructive ones empowering ones
disempowering ones positive and negative
neural patterns called beliefs
the key is to deactivate
the beliefs that disempower you and to
create a new belief that matches the
vision and goal you have
then we have the fears that i talked
about i'm going to give you a couple
techniques
if you have a fear of
having a goal and failing
you're not going to take action because
as soon as that circuit turns on
for the failure circuit which is the
fear circuit and guess what happens
all of the motivation that you had goes
out the window and you either fight
freeze or flee meaning running away
doing something else like procrastinate
instead of doing what you need to do so
if you have a fear of failure a fear of
success a fear of being embarrassed
ashamed ridiculed or judged
these are going to turn off your
motivational centers and activate your
fear centers so i'm not going to leave
you hanging without a solution
first and foremost understand that you
and i became conditioned because of our
parents our teachers television radio
our experiences what we heard what we
saw what meanings we gave things which
means that we became conditioned we
weren't born with any beliefs or fears
of self-image challenges
we developed them and in neuroscience
and neuropsychology terms means
that we develop the patterns that got
reinforced that become the natural
easy way for us to be even though we may
not want it so
what if you wrote down a limiting belief
that you had
okay i'm not smart enough not good
enough not worthy i don't have the money
i don't have the time i don't have this
i'm too young i'm too old write out
whatever you want
and then what if
you just created a new language pattern
and reframed it and said in the past
i used to believe fill in the blank and
now i believe that i am smart enough i
am good enough i am worthy i can achieve
this i can't find the money i can
upgrade my knowledge i can't upgrade my
skills and i'm excited and enthusiastic
to achieve the vision and goal of and
write in the blank now
if you wrote that out
and you repeated it and emotionalized it
and felt it as if you were a hollywood
actor or actress learning a new role you
would activate something called the
neuroplasticity switch in your brain
that would cause new neurons to connect
and if you reinforced it for the next
hundred days by reading it
emotionalizing it recording it and
listening to it
you would take a new pattern that you
wrote out and then you would impress it
through space repetition repetition okay
is what is required in order to
strengthen and reinforce a neural
pattern and practice is what makes
permanent let me repeat practicing a
paragraph or an affirmation of what you
want is what makes permanent what that
means is it makes the neural network
permanent and it replaces the old
pattern it takes 66 days to 365 days to
do this so don't do it for a week going
nothing's happening
66 days to 365 days that's for limiting
beliefs
slow down
and create plans let me explain when i
was younger
i would take
every single day as a challenge to get
as many things as i could done
however
i didn't take the time
to really focus on
the things that were gonna make the
biggest impact in my business i gave
everything
the same value
and so yes i was busy yes i was getting
things done
but if i could go back in time
i would focus on
what is the plan
that's going to move me down the road to
achieve the business success that i want
faster and easier versus versus harder
and more complex
and
now as i am almost going to be 60
i think about
time and i've done some videos in the
past on
there's no such thing as time management
all you can do is manage what you do in
time but in order to know what you
should do in time you have to think
about
what are the objectives that you want to
achieve in your business and in business
there's obviously sales marketing
finance management product development
technology etc
but there are certain things that you
need to do
before you do the other things and what
i've discovered
is we tend to gravitate towards the
things that interest us and are easy for
us to do but business isn't like that in
business
there are critical things that you have
to do
if you're serious about building a
business that actually works for you
instead of you working for it
so one of the things
that is really really important is that
you take the time to find out what are
the building blocks for your type of
business whether you're online or
offline so um i have my vision boards
and i actually have my exceptional life
blueprint that i've created it's about
50 pages
of my prayers my rituals
for my spiritual growth health wealth my
money story my intermission my outer
mission
you know some of the stuff you know
either that i have or that i'm creating
and so i create these visual
representations to trigger the biggest
part of my brain called the occipital
lobe and to activate my memory center
so i have vision boards for what i want
to create so i'm giving my brain
the exact instructions so that not only
it focuses helping me achieve that
but most people don't understand about
vision boards or creating goals in
writing that are specific is that your
brain
is a deletion and distortion
tool as well
so if you give your brain the
instruction of this is the stuff that's
important to me for health god
spirituality charity fun experiences my
children my mother my father myself
whatever it is and you say this is what
i want to trade my life for delete and
distort everything else now all of a
sudden you're using your brain as a
deletion of distortion
organism in order to be able to help you
hyper focus on what you want so i got
really inquisitive and curious early on
with
can i control more of the cause
of my results
and that required responsibility and
when i was younger it was like i was
more into the blame game it's because of
him because of her because of it because
of the market because of where i live
because of my mother my father
how old i am or how young i am how asian
or caucasian i am it doesn't make a
difference so a lot of my
upbringing
caused me to look outside of myself
and when i
looked
inside myself and took the
i guess the
prerequisite of
responsibility i own it yes i can change
it
that transformed my life that you know
that really started to to put things
into perspective so mark waldman in his
um
little training over here says
seven days of gratitude exercise the
more you focus on your thoughts the more
your brain becomes habituated to it the
brain the brain tends to pay more
attention to negative thoughts this is
based on the instinctual parts of the
brain we can train ourselves to focus on
the positives as well
at the end of the day he says
write down three things you feel
grateful for and three things you did
well
this can change your brain you only have
to for seven days and you will see your
self-esteem grow for three months so
when we are giving you you know uh
gratitude things to do anything we're
teaching you to do it's all based in
neuroscience research and so the more
you're grateful the more you have to be
grateful for the more you train your
brain to be grateful the more it looks
and becomes habituated to look for other
things to be grateful for there's
einstein which represents our left
prefrontal cort cortex the
the smart genius part of our brain that
has imagination that can come up with
all the ideas of what about this what
about this i can have this i can have
this but what most people don't
understand is we also have right a
frankenstein part of our brain the inner
critic you know it says but you're not
good enough you're not smart enough what
if you fail what if you're embarrassed
what if you're ashamed so we have this
you know that's why i have them there's
einstein and there's frankenstein just
to remind me and to remind my students
that both exist within us
and our goal is to understand that you
know the way our brain works is there's
always a protective side of our brain so
frankenstein's always going what if you
fail what if you succeed and fail what
if you disappoint yourself and
einstein's going don't worry about it
imagine the future and so there's this
constant battle in our brains you know
going on in our goal and meditation is
one of the best ways to recognize that
both exist
and both are right your frankenstein
part of your brain is there to protect
you your einstein brain is
ready to help you achieve your goals and
dreams and the key is to remember you're
not your brain you're not the einstein
part you're not the frankenstein part
there's another side of you that is much
greater than all of it for me i thought
i was afraid of public speaking right i
thought that was oh i would just say i'm
a bad public speaker that was my story
well you're absolutely right what you
said that's what it was i was afraid of
judgment i was afraid of rejection and
that was what was holding me back and
these are subconscious patterns
right so the feeling okay is this
uncomfortable which is very
uncomfortable uh it's it's stressful
it's it creates anxiety
and so it's not the public speaking
so the question is where did you
learn to have this idea that
speaking in public causes you to be
embarrassed ashamed ridiculed or judged
and here's what a lot of people will say
if you ask them like where did that come
from they'll say well you know when i
was a kid in class and you know the
teacher asked the question and i
answered and the answer was wrong you
know the other kids made fun of me
or the teacher said no that's not the
right answer and and and you know they
were embarrassed and the other kids
ridiculed them and so like who wants
that
so if our brain
is focusing on wiring
whatever keeps us safe and whatever
keeps pain away
we avoid pain or we'll do anything to
avoid pain
way before we do anything to gain
pleasure
and so survival first avoidance of pain
second before we gain pleasure so if
there's any real or imagined danger
where we're gonna be emotionally hurt
mentally hurt physically hurt
financially hurt
our brain gives us this signal be aware
this may be one of those times
it says be aware this may be one of
those times and so
the the cycle the neural circuit the
cycle shouldn't stop there
but when you people haven't been trained
on here are my six core emotions here
are my feelings that those emotions
cause and here's what to do when this
emotion is triggered do this
when this emotion is triggered do that
and what you want to do is learn when
the emotion of fear is triggered
the neurochemistry is adrenaline
cortisol epinephrine norepinephrine
that's like this high anxiety rocket
fuel within us now in most people
it caused them to just stop put on the
brake but how is it that a firefighter
okay
could could see a building blowing up in
front of them a building crashing down a
raging fire
and yet she musters up the courage to
use that fuel from fear and go in
it's because she's been trained yep
that's because she's been trained i
tend to be a goal-seeking guy right
and i used to not celebrate the small
stuff and i just just like you know find
a bigger goal bigger goal bigger goal
more bigger bigger and somebody says to
me like are you gonna like slow down
just to enjoy some of the stuff that you
actually have done for yourself and for
people in your family and i was like
well uh
let me create an accomplished board
oh good so good
so accomplish board you pass that test
on your own 40 years ago
celebrate that you helped this person
who was challenged celebrate that you
know you did this for him or for her or
for yourself celebrate that stuff to
remind yourself
cause i i'm tough on myself like i'm
like i'm let's come on let's go it's a
goal let's go
um and sometimes i forget the stuff that
i have done the stuff that i do do that
i need to remember so i created an
accomplishments board and a list so i
can just go to it when i feel like holy
am i am i smart enough to achieve that
next thing am i good enough what a lot
of people don't know ed is so good when
i was a kid i used to feel like i wasn't
smart enough
and when i was a kid it held me back
and today i still feel like i'm not
smart enough and that fuels me to get
smarter so i use it
like i said big goals like oh god i
don't have the skills i don't have the
knowledge but i can figure it out i've
got contacts i've got friends there's
books there's google there's there's
youtube there's holy mackerel i don't
need to have all the specialized
knowledge anymore whenever you're
looking to to grow spiritually
emotionally mentally physically there's
going to be lessons involved and if you
don't learn the lesson you can repeat it
that's number one but more importantly
when you're doing things on planet earth
in the physical realm
you have to do the right things in the
right order at the right time and nature
doesn't care
about whether you make mistakes or not
you are going to pay the consequences of
those mistakes
and so when we make errors in our
judgment or we make errors in our timing
or we make errors in our tactics
we pay the consequences and that's just
part of the game
and i personally believe that we're
playing in a precision model game
and so there's nothing that's out of
order in the universe so if nothing's
out of order my job
is to be in resonance with the order
that already exists
and that is for me resonance or
um you know chaos so i don't look at it
as attraction i don't think that we
attract you know stuff to us the the way
most people think about it is that
resonance though because you know i
believe we live in an energetic world is
the resonance based on a frequency or a
vibration yeah so if you sit at the
piano and you hit the a440 key
chances are that the chandelier that's
in resonance with that is going to start
vibrating even though there's no strings
between the two so through the medium of
air
anything that's in resonance is in this
attractive state or in this coherence
state
by the same token if you hit the a330
key
you're not gonna hit that chandelier
frequency and the same is true with the
tuning fork
right so if you have a tuning fork and
you hit a certain key the tuning fork
will start to vibrate that's resonance a
lot of people think well that's
attraction no it's not attraction it
doesn't work that way from all the
research that i have mustered so my job
and we get into some of the brain stuff
is if you think about
a radio
if you turn on a radio and you want to
hear 95 point uh if you want to hear
classical music you might go to 95.5
and it tunes into a frequency that's
already here
it's not attracting it it's already here
if you don't like classical music you go
to 103.3
and you have punk rock it's already here
so how do we use that as a corollary
relationship to if my brain is the
world's most sophisticated
electromagnetic switching station is it
possible that i can tune into
frequencies of what's already here and
the answer is yes
that's resonance and so we can tune in
on a spiritual emotional mental and
physical level and when you create that
coherence then all of a sudden you start
to be in the awareness of everything
that's already here that you weren't in
coherence with before and people say
well i must be attracting it no no no it
was already here how do you
stand out from the competition i want
you to think about this and this is
based on
seth godin's book
called purple cow i want you to imagine
you're walking
okay in the country area and off in the
distance you see a herd of cows
and big deal there's just cows but what
would you do
if
one cow
was purple
what would you do if one cow was purple
you'd go
holy
look at the purple cow
let me ask you a question
when people look at your product or your
service your offering whether it's on
your website your landing pages radio
television billboards
when you speak
do they go holy mackerel that's unique
that's different
that i have to pay attention to
right do they say that
right and so miriam is saying i would
pay attention to that cow right why
because it's different it's it's unique
so biggest mistake
that people make in 2021 that i want you
to stop
is i want you to think but if you just
start to think about
you know what can i do to stand out like
a purple cow
that'll put you ahead of 90 of business
owners right now because they don't
figure that out they don't understand
that in order to
clear through the clutter of all the
noise you have to stand out first every
single brand has an identity and the
identity comes with it you know a
certain color
a certain way of being an identity means
something to people
right so
when you are thinking about you as your
personal brand
what
is the identity of your brand
right is it uh is it mercedes-benz or
volkswagen is it adidas or nike you know
is it
bright colors or
dull colors every brand has an identity
and you have to choose
okay when you are building your personal
brand an identity that resonates with
who you are when you're a personal brand
you have to be an authentic you
and so in order for your brand to show
up as you okay
what does your brand say about you so
here is the couple here are a couple of
questions
that
you may consider
many of you have followed my work for
quite some time would you agree
that there's a consistent theme
about what i teach and how i teach it
right is there a consistent theme around
mindset around skill set and around
action set do you notice that if you
followed my work you know for a year or
two or three or four you know i
specialize on the neuroscience and
neuropsychology of success that's my
theme
my underlying theme
if you've noticed
another part of my brand is consistency
right so i show up
tuesdays every tuesday right here at
nine o'clock
um pacific time which is san diego
right so
when you are thinking about your
personal brand i want you to take out a
sheet of paper and i want you to write
down what does your personal brand
look like
if you take a look at you know my book
you know inner size
okay my newest best-selling book not not
the answer but inner size if you take a
look at having it all if you take a look
at the colors
you know in my office on the wall right
look at that the colors on the wall
if you take a look
at the colors
you know of my company neuro gym there's
a consistency of colors right
right there's a consistency of colors
and so one of the things that you have
to understand when you're developing a
personal brand is your your developing
coherence in somebody's brain around
your colors your theme what you stand
for what you're all about and so the
first thing to consider when you're
developing your personal brand
is first to define what is your personal
brand how specifically am i going to
achieve that goal like what are the
strategies and the tactics meaning what
are you going to do
how specifically are you going to do it
by when
right so now when we have you know an
attitude
of goal achievement of getting clear on
the goal coming up with what i'm gonna
do on monday at nine o'clock and here's
how i'm gonna do it and here's whose
help i need i'm gonna put it right into
my calendar and i'm gonna take inspired
action and when an obstacle comes in my
way
i'm going to ask myself empowering
questions like
how can i overcome this obstacle what
can i do
to overcome this obstacle whose help do
i need what book can i read what do i
need to search on google what youtube
video can i watch to overcome this
obstacle where can i learn better
strategies and tactics to make what i do
more efficient more productive more
constructive versus me just working hard
and long trying to do what to do
there's a formula called ppp equals ppp
and it goes like this piss poor planning
equals piss poor performance
and many people
i have found
don't have any
real plans
for what they're gonna do today
this week this month this quarter they
show up every morning
okay without a road map
to go from where they are to where they
want to be by the end of the day
so what are you going to do today
to achieve your health goals your wealth
goals your relationship goals your
career goals your business goals your
fun goals the experiences you want your
charitable goals what are you going to
do today or this week to move yourself
forward to make progress every single
day then what are you going to do
to manage your
mindset and your emotions what are you
going to do to overcome the obstacles
that are in your way whether the mental
obstacles physical obstacles financial
obstacles strategical obstacles tactical
obstacles
now you may be watching me right now
going oh my god there's so much stuff
there well yeah if you want to achieve
goals
there's a thinking
there is a feeling and there's a
behavior that gets you there and there's
also a thinking a feeling and a behavior
that does not get you there most people
you know confuse
activity with productivity they confuse
setting goals from achieving goals they
don't understand that you have to create
some kind of a road map
to reduce the resistance and uncertainty
and stress and fear and anxiety in your
brain so that you activate your
motivational centers
the motive for action center in your
brain so that you actually take action
instead of repeating your old patterns
over and over again when i first learned
about the law of attraction i was 19
years old
but i was taught that with the law of
attraction also is the law of goya and
nobody talks about the law of goya i've
been around is that christian people
no
no but the law of goya is the get off my
grandmother don't marry a jewish girl
that was the law of goya that's awesome
right
no the law of god is to get off your ass
law
right and so a lot of people who think
about this law of attraction stuff is is
you know sit there like a monk you know
and meditate and visualize and believe
and write your goals down and that's
going to happen for you and
it's just rob
um i don't have any friends
zero that don't bust their ass
on in pursuit of what they want
in addition to being in resonance with
it and and attracting it they are
busting their ass every day every week
every month every quarter every year ups
and downs highs and lows things that
work things that don't and they keep
moving forward to make it happen
and they find along the way they get
some lucky breaks when you're developing
new habits
i want you to develop
small
repeatable
consistent
easy let me repeat small repeatable
consistent
easy things to do for a new habit for
100 days
if you want to become a person who reads
a lot
read
one sentence or one paragraph a day for
a hundred days
preferably around the same time if you
want to start exercising to be healthier
i want you to start exercising for one
minute a day for 100 days or 30 seconds
or three minutes you choose the
minimal possible uh behavior that you
can do to develop the habit the habit is
more important than the intensity
at first
you want to reduce
all the neurological stress of change
you want to reduce all the neurological
processes that are built for you to
conserve energy and not develop new
habits so you have to create a new
habit loop
and the way you do that is small
repeatable easy consistent behaviors
for 100 days don't worry about
anything other than that if you want to
develop a new
thought pattern
think in a certain way every day for 100
days and schedule a time create your own
trigger when you wake up when you go to
sleep after sex uh before the bathroom
before you brush your teeth whatever it
is
if you can just commit to small little
behaviors for 100 days
you'll develop the foundation of a new
habit where you do the habit then the
habit creates you let me give an example
what if i said to you hey
joel let's do this business venture
together you put up 20 grand i'll put up
20 grand uh you'll take care of
podcasting sales marketing networking
i'll take care of this this and that and
let's do this together we'd probably get
excited
um well what would happen if you start
to think about well what if it doesn't
work what if i don't deliver this what
if i can't do this what if you know i
lose my money what if i do that and
that's a normal discussion to have and
what if i told you by the way after we
do the deal here's the way you're going
to think you're going to have a whole
bunch of these negative thoughts you're
going to have a whole bunch of these
negative emotions you're going to have a
whole bunch of these sensations that you
want to move away from and that's going
to be normal here's what i want you to
do
flip the switch
flip from this right prefrontal cortex
which is supposed to do that for you and
let's flip you over to the left
prefrontal cortex which is the genius
part of your brain i'm gonna say okay
great when that happens i want you to
flip the switch like that and shift over
and see both sides if we do invest
together if we do execute a plan if we
do what we say we're going to do is it
possible that we will hit our income
goals hit our our uh net revenue goals
be able to do this and this and this and
this and this and this and this and this
and as soon as you can help somebody
make that switch
get from one part of the brain that's
the pessimistic we call it the
frankenstein part of the brain and the
other side is the optimistic strategic
thinker that can connect to all
possibilities at all times and that's
the left prefrontal cortex and that's
where the genius part of you is and
that's why i have mr albert einstein
there to always remind me activate left
prefrontal cortex and be aware of the
right prefrontal cortex which is for the
most part just bringing up memories from
my 55 years on this planet the good the
bad and the ugly yeah so it's a
frankenstein and the einstein i like it
when
when einstein is working
you are dreaming in the world of
possibilities how can i what can i do
who can i talk to how will it work what
should i read who should i network with
what are the possibilities what are the
tools i need what the resource i need
and all the possibilities open up pay
myself first
let me explain when i first started re
max of indiana
even though money was coming into the
company
i wasn't taking any money out and i
worked for for months and years on end
you know just putting everything back in
the business and that created a lot of
stress in the early years and so what i
would do differently now
is i would value myself more and i would
take an income
or take a percentage of the revenues on
an ongoing basis so that i got paid for
the services that i provided to my
business now when you
put yourself
up on the pedestal where you deserve
and you pay yourself you actually build
your self-confidence you build your
self-worth you build your self-esteem
and you get paid for the services
rendered when you pay everybody else
first
you are putting everybody else in front
of you and you are the number one person
that you need to keep motivated and it
doesn't matter how much it is that you
pay yourself
it has to be something for the effort
and the work that you do so at least you
build your own self-worth and value
a lot of times when we are focusing on
what we've lost
or what we're losing
we're not focusing on what we've gained
a lot of times we're focusing okay on
what's possible as a result of this
we tend to mono focus right on either
good or bad
i like it i don't like it it tastes good
it doesn't it's hurting me it's not but
what if you could learn how to observe
both
what if you could
observe the law of polarity
in its entirety that says you cannot
have an electron without a proton and in
without an out and up without a noun you
cannot have that on this planet in this
universe
so is it possible that with just a
little bit of training whether it's
mindfulness or meditation or awareness
you can be
sad you can grieve
and be joyful and happy at the same time
see it's when we are afraid that we're
losing something
that we've got that frankenstein brain
of ours saying what if what if what if
what if oh my god oh my god oh my god oh
my god oh my god
when we are in that state
we can't be focused on what are we going
to do about it
now in a grieving state like with my
mother um the only thing i want to do
about is make sure that we respect and
honor her life
and my brothers and sisters and my dad
etc
so i need to focus on that
and when we're talking about
you know a business going under a
relationship you know that's unraveling
right now
if you're focusing on all of the
disempowering emotions and circumstances
you cannot
be focusing on the solution to that
possible problem so you have to learn
how to manage the emotions and for those
who don't know what that's like i want
you to imagine i just got really mad
a hollywood actor or actress learns that
they are not their emotions they have
emotions
now everybody's going to grieve
differently but i want people to
understand that you don't have to be
disempowered
in grief
you can be empowered in grief
and everybody's going to do it
differently and some people are going to
go inside some will go outside
but we have the ability
to frame things in ways that empower us
and gives us the best chance to move
forward instead of being a victim of it
and all i'm saying is
consider consider that you have way more
power than you are displaying
in your emotional management in your
focus in your awareness and in your
behavior and you can feel the entire
spectrum of emotions totally cool with
that but are you being
constructive
versus destructive in your behaviors
cognitive priming right so what's
cognitive prime so think about this when
um a baby is learning how to eat okay
what does you know
mommy or daddy do mommy or daddy you
know takes the spoon and you know she
puts it in the jar she pretends to eat
it herself and then she puts it into the
baby's mouth
open the mouth
and she does that to cue the baby's
brain of what to do so she pretends
she's doing it herself she gets the baby
to do it and through this repetition a
baby will learn spoon in the hand in the
jar spoon has food on it mommy's opening
her mouth she's bringing it to me open
my mouth i put the food in my mouth oh
this yummy thing feels so good
eat this food
and so if you think about what's
actually happening we're getting the
motor cortex of her brain going we're
getting her taste buds going you know at
a certain point we'll put the spoon in
her mouth and put her hand in the jar so
that she could do it for herself so
we're priming her through visual cues
through auditory cues through taste cues
right through all of the different
senses we're priming her brain and then
we're reinforcing it
day after day after day after day to
create the neural network the
connections in the brain that if i want
that yummy food in my mouth i have to
learn how to take the spoon in my hand
put it in the jar get it all over the
place initially until i could do it
without spilling it all over the place
well that takes you know weeks and
months and years to tie your shoes to
learn how to eat to learn how to brush
your teeth all these things that are
automatic now yes all the things that
are automatic now so before something's
automatic
it's not yeah yeah and it can feel
really uncomfortable so so let's take um
a disempowering belief that you have i'm
not good enough i'm not smart i'm too
young i'm too old i'm female i'm
whatever it is you have a disempowering
belief it's a nothing more than a
pattern in the brain so somehow
a pattern that wasn't there before
got there
right who told you that your parents
your teachers your brother your sister
your best friend said ah you'll never
like who did that it's really irrelevant
but if the pattern is there and it's a
dominant pattern because you've believed
it for 20 30 40 years whatever the case
might be
and it's been reinforced
what does brain sign say about how the
do i get rid of it and it says well
you'll never get rid of it but you can
deactivate it
okay
how do i deactivate it
right how do i deactivate it so every
time i catch myself saying i'm not good
enough or fill in the blank feel take
any limiting belief
and any time you catch yourself saying
it or feeling it
what if you said to yourself
stop
in the past i used to believe that and
now i believe i'm more than good enough
in the past i used to feel like i'm too
young but now i can use my age as a
benefit to achieve that goal
[Music]
any limiting belief we can do one of a
couple things we can say in the past i
used to
and so what we're doing is we're not
saying no stop that we're not
reinforcing a limiting belief by trying
to fight it we acknowledge it's just a
pattern
and just say in the past i used to
believe that and now here's what i'm
choosing to believe
so now what i'm doing is i'm taking an
existing neural pattern and i'm
changing the pattern i'm taking away its
energetic force by adding new words that
i'm choosing now versus the ones that
were given to me or the ones that i felt
when i was too young to actually change
it on my own then so now i'm paying
attention to my self-talk i'm paying
attention i'm paying attention to the
inner critic let's say you know you and
i are buddies we want to start a
business or we have a business come on
let's crush it all right let's do this
thing let's triple our income this year
let's make 30 more net revenues let's
travel the world let's live this
lifestyle that's amazing and we get
excited right so we go oh yeah oh my god
that's great let's do this high fives
all around dopamine's release we feel
great we shared with our friends we
release oxytocin so we bonded oh my god
i love you and you love me and we feel
great we're going to conquer the world
and that happens all the time
but let's say
that underneath the hood
there's
a fear of
i'm not smart enough
or i'm not good enough
or what if i fail
and i embarrass myself what if i succeed
and i can't maintain it what if i'm
ridiculed because i try so hard and my
friends will laugh at me
there are fifty five zero
different types of fears
that are almost in everybody's memory
bank that gets brought up to the surface
and when the fear circuit lights up
which is bam
automatically within either moments
hours or days when you start realizing
holy what is it going to really take to
double or triple my income and and to
take the time off that i want as soon as
that happens
when the fierce circuit lights up
then the system the the neuroelectrical
chemical system floods with epinephrine
cortisol and norepinephrine what is that
those are just three of the hundred
chemicals in the brain
that are part of the stress response
system whenever
you and i
and everybody watching or listening
thinks about or feels
that there is potential
danger potential pain whether it's
emotional pain like being embarrassed or
ashamed or financial pain like not being
able to have enough money to pay for my
food or for my burger for my cocktails
or for my rent or my car or my airline
ticket if there is real or imagined
possibility of
discomfort pain
the brake on motivation slams shut
and we start to procrastinate
so we have this incredible system that
can
give us this motivation the motive for
action to go forward but we have to
temper it with our ability to recognize
the trigger and the sensation
in our body called a feeling
that the non-conscious processing part
of the brain that gives us this emotion
called fear
all fear is processed at the
non-conscious level of your awareness
and then gives rise into the frontal
lobes
of the feeling that your body has the
average person
that has not been trained
feels fear
and puts the brake on
and goes and retreats into what they're
comfortable doing
the successful person either
they may be genetically wired to
understand feeling fear and doing it
anyway turning their fear into fuel but
that's not the majority of people that's
why 90 plus percent of people fail and
stay in that position but you can take
that fuel that hypersensitive rocket
fuel i call it and utilize it to
actually motivate you faster further
than you ever got before
yeah fascinating systems if you don't
know how to use them too bad it's like
not knowing that a gun has got bullets
in it and you pull the tree the holy
just blew my brains out
not that you'd be able to you know say
that they'd be like game over but
ignorance is not your friend when it
comes to neurochemistry at the time i
was 22 years old trying to work trying
to make make money and i wanted to
figure out what was causing
my ulcer rate of colitis because the
ulcer rate of colitis was an effect
right so i was like what was causing it
and what i realized was causing it was a
lot of stress the wrong foods too much
alcohol no exercise etc so i said okay
well how could i heal myself and at the
time i was taking 25 pills a day i was
doing enemas in the morning enemas at
night and going to the hospital once a
month for them to stick a tube in my
rectum to see what was happening in my
colon not fun at 22 years old it's like
what the
front door right uh and so i said okay
let me see if i could really heal myself
and so i wrote an affirmation i wish i
had it here because i'd read you it says
my body and all its organs were created
by the infinite intelligence in my
subconscious mind it created all my
bones tissues muscles uh liver lungs
heart and everything else within me it
knows how to heal me i am now perfectly
healthy that's a short version of that
and every day in addition to eating well
exercising sleeping well i would read
this affirmation i would close my eyes i
would see my colon healed i would see my
colon sick i'd see my colon heal i'd see
my colon six sick i'd see my colon
healed that's called mental contrasting
in the world of neuroscience
and so i would see this
over and over and over and over and over
and over and over and over and over and
over in my brain i would read it i would
feel it i would see it
five weeks of doing this after two and a
half years of being sick
all of my symptoms went away a hundred
percent when i went in to see my doctor
his name was dr wu he said to me
you've had a spontaneous remission i
said it's not a spontaneous remission it
was a deliberate remission
that was 36 years ago all right and the
doctor says whatever you're doing you
know keep doing he says but i want you
to still take the pills i was taking 25
pills a day i said to him i said doctor
wu you don't understand do you
i said i fixed the cause you still want
to treat the symptoms
right and so
i have shown people how to get off of
colitis crohn's disease diverticulitis
our body is consistently
re-manifesting itself based on our
thoughts emotions feelings sensations
and behaviors so what if
everyone watching what if i could be in
a vibration mentally
heart wise right emotionally and gut
wise so heart
brain heart and gut what if i can create
alignment so that i am in a state of
health so my body is regenerating
healthy cells my body is regenerating
you know or activating energy from my
mitochondria what if i could be in this
alignment with
the flow of health versus a flow of dis
ease
so for you
you know what happens with most people
is they're focusing on their dis ease or
their pain
instead of channeling their attention
and energy and focusing on health
and well-being
so the more you say you know my neck is
broken my neck is broken i got a little
thing in my neck it's painful my neck
the doctors say i can't this is
impossible the more you keep reinforcing
the cellular activity that reinforces
that well when the fear signal has
kicked in
all right it's releasing the
neurochemicals like i said epinephrine
cortisol norepinephrine which is
adrenaline um and some of it's good too
much of it will cause you to fight
to freeze
to flee run away or to faint those are
the four
okay possible outcomes for the stress
response or fear response system when it
kicks in so when that switch is turned
on think of it as a light switch that
just turned on in your brain and then
there's a cascade
okay of neurochemicals that causes a
feeling
if you focus on the feeling then you're
gonna think about what you feel then
you're gonna feel what you think about
you create this self-fulfilling doom
loop of neurochemicals being rushed in
your body and if you do that every day
every week every month over and over
again you've now just set up a doom loop
habit where that fear is going to drive
your thoughts and emotions and behaviors
or lack thereof but what i want you to
do
is recognize the fear
calmly
and you do this
as soon as you recognize the fear that
you can bring up on your own you do the
first inner size okay inner size
exercise for your physical body and your
organs inner size for your neuro muscles
all right so
when you feel fear
be in observation of it like the light
comes on in the dash of your car
and then what you do is you take 60
breaths but here's how you do it
in through your nose
out through your mouth like you're
blowing out of a straw so it goes like
this
six breaths 10 seconds each ready
deep rhythmic breath in up to the lungs
expand the diaphragm so you get the
diaphragm and the lungs expanding
and you breathe out like you're
breathing through a straw so you focus
the energy
out
through the mouth it causes your brain
to actually get
oxygenated
and guess why you want that well when
we're in a state of fear we activate
okay the vagus nerve which constricts
your blood flow it slows down your
heartbeat it causes shallow breathing so
as soon as you
alternate from that fear and stress
response system to the calm
the i'm sorry from the from the stress
and react system to the calm and respond
system
your brain shuts off the fear circuit
and activates
the left prefrontal cortex and when you
can think because blood flows back there
again so if fear is holding you back
there's nothing wrong with fear
but there just
may be
um
a lack of skill of knowing
when or what to do does this make sense
so far does this make sense so far so
when you take those six deep rhythmic
breaths
that is what deactivates that stress
response system in the brain and
activates the relax and respond you want
to be in a responsive state
as much as possible
versus a reactive state one of the
um i guess most unbelievable discoveries
of the last hundred years is that our
brain can create new neural connections
new beliefs new habits new perceptions
um new um neural muscles and reinforced
neural muscles and so if you look at the
problem she says with curiosity
and with this approach she says a lot of
people focus on debt and they go oh my
god look at the debt i'm in how am i
going to get out
here's the problem i can't pay this i
can't do this she knows now when you sit
down and you look at the debt and you
write down you brainstorm
how to get out of debt and make more
wealth
and write down every idea that you can
come up with she goes you activate the
creativity neural muscle and the more
you practice it
the more you teach yourself how to focus
on the solution instead of the problem
the more you're flipping
your neuroplasticity switch but the more
you're flipping on your curiosity
imagination and creativity circuits
training your brain
is so critical you can train your brain
to be aware acutely aware of your senses
of what are my sensations what's my
heartbeat doing right now what's my
breathing doing right now am i anxious
and nervous and stressed is my
sympathetic nervous system activated
or am i calm
relaxed able to think clearly can i
respond instead of being in this
reactive state that's a skill when the
sympathetic nervous system has kicked in
you're in your flight or fight response
mechanism so you're breathing shallowly
you're tense your heartbeat's elevated
you might feel like you're sweating a
little bit and it's just tense
and parasympathetic is calm observe
pay attention be aware be mindful
choose deliberately versus reactively
if somebody's unhappy could you teach
yourself to be happy in less than three
seconds and the answer is yes if you
chose to so control of emotions control
of emotions and so when we focus on
the the core emotions people have of
happiness sadness shame
disgust contempt love
we can learn how to switch between those
on any given moment
but most people what happens they get
caught up in this emotion energy in
motion that's negative or disempowering
and then they think about how they feel
and they feel what they're thinking
about and they keep perpetuating the
same pattern
and that's not where it ends and this is
where the problem lays is if you do that
on a regular basis
your brain says since you're repeating
this
let me just make this
um you know a habit and i'll just create
that on command-free so you're in that
state more frequently let's say
you have a goal okay any goal um a
financial goal a travel goal a net worth
goal uh have my own blog post or blog
and and have a tribe follow me goal and
that's your vision and your goal that
you've consciously chosen
but then beneath the surface
you feel
am i really worthy of that
am i really good enough
am i really smart enough do i really
deserve that any time you have a vision
or a goal
that is positive and and fun and amazing
but there is a subconscious
negative or disempowering pattern like
self-esteem self-worth or self-image
the negative disempowering pattern wins
98 of the time wow
so if you think about the positive
vision and goal as being the you know
the positive if we have the positive and
the negative we have chaos in the brain
and what we really want to create more
of is coherence so what's coherence well
imagine you um if everybody just
think about going to your favorite band
your favorite band's coming to town
all right and you are so excited because
you just love to hear them but
um their drummer or their lead vocalist
or their guitarist got sick a few days
ago and they had to get somebody else to
play you know tonight when you're going
to see them play and they haven't had a
chance to practice together and this new
band member is just not in tune with
everybody else there's going to be chaos
it's like oh he's off the vocals are off
or or the piano's off or the guitar is
off it just doesn't sound right or feel
right and then the whole thing's awesome
it's off so it's like the experience is
like there's no harmony here
right so
when people's vision or goals are out of
harmony with their subconscious
self-esteem or fears or limiting beliefs
there's chaos and there isn't there's
too much friction and the action in the
absence of
a friction you have smooth but when
there's friction there it's just not
smooth it's not in harmony it's like a
muscle your brain has neuro muscles
okay right so you think about you know
we have if we want to build our bicep
muscle or our chest or our shoulders or
our legs we go to the gym we do
exercises or we go and hike or run or
bike or walk or do whatever it is well
what do you do to strengthen your
confidence muscle
what do you do to strengthen your
self-esteem muscle what do you do to
strengthen your tenacity or resolve
muscle what do you do
to to strengthen any of your core
neural muscles like awareness how do you
strengthen your awareness how do you
strengthen your ability to focus and
stay laser
disciplined on an achievement of a goal
these are all neural muscles that you
can strengthen so the first inner size
that you teach anyway it's kind of like
learning the alphabet first so take six
common the circuits there's three
foundational inner sides we teach in the
book there's many more but the first one
is just to deactivate the stress
reactive center in the brain and you do
that through six deep breaths in 10
second increments so you take a deep
breath in through your nose
and then as you blow out pretend you're
blowing out through a straw so all of
your energy is towards that focus right
so three two one
you do that six times and we can see in
brain scan images that the stress
response center lowers and in many cases
deactivates which throws blood back to
the left prefrontal cortex your state of
awareness increases and then you can
move to inner size number two which is
called aya aia which is now in a calm
relaxed state
now
the first a stands for awareness of my
thoughts emotions feelings sensations
and what have been my behaviors for
let's say the last five minutes or hour
awareness without shame blame guilt
justification or judgment pure awareness
calm state then what is my intention
well my intention is to be happy i've
been feeling sad my intentions to be
happy my intention is to be focused not
scattered great let me let me write give
myself one or two intentions then the
next a stands for what's one action to
move me towards that so if your
intention is to be happy why not look up
and smile
just look up and smile because when you
look up and smile you release the
neurochemistry of happiness and you
cannot look up and be angry sad mad
discipline you cannot and if you look up
and smile we are
wired to look up to heaven let's say and
be hopeful and we are wired that when we
smile the neurochemistry of happiness is
firing through our bloodstream and so if
you just do inner size number one and
two now you get awareness and you calm
down the circuits and then if you learn
inner size number three it's called
actors it's called
um
actress uh no hold on sorry i'm losing
inner size number three uh it is called
uh it'll come back to me in just a
moment but the the um
the third inner size is around it's an
actor's studio exercise basically it's
an inner size so any actor in the world
can switch from being happy or sad or
mad or disappointed or or any modality
of physiology that you want them to take
on
they can command it on command right
right and so if somebody's unhappy could
you teach yourself to be happy in less
than three seconds and the answer is yes
if you chose to so control of emotion
control of emotions and so when we focus
on
the the core emotions people have of
happiness sadness shame uh disgust
contempt love
we can learn how to switch between those
on any given moment
but most people what happens they get
caught up in this emotion energy in
motion that's negative or disempowering
and then they think about how they feel
and they feel what they're thinking
about and they keep perpetuating the
same pattern
and that's not where it ends and this is
where the problem lays is if you do that
on a regular basis your brain says since
you're repeating this
let me just make this
you know a habit and i'll just create
that on command-free so you're in that
state more frequently and then they
don't know how to interrupt that pattern
and create a new empowered state stop
buying into the fear that's happening in
the marketplace right now
um coronavirus fear high alert fear what
if i get it what if i know if i get
fired or people buying or people not
buying fear faith what if negative oh my
god oh my god oh my god
what if i get laid off what if i succeed
and then fail what if it doesn't work
what if i discipline yourself stop
buying into the fear i want you to
imagine this
almost eight billion humans okay
8 billion humans on earth
not everybody
is
into the fear not everybody can't afford
stuff not everybody um is in jeopardy
whether it's their business or
financially now i understand a lot of
people are hurting so i don't want to
take away from that okay
yes there are a lot of people hurting
some of those people that are hurting
have money some don't some are scared
some are not so what i want you to
understand is whatever your own mindset
is about what's happening out there
is what you are creating
in here there are plenty of people who
want what you have your product your
service your knowledge your skill
whatever it is that you can offer them
maybe this group doesn't want it right
now maybe this group can't afford it
right now but if you're focusing on this
group in this group
you're missing this group that needs it
and wants it right now more than any
other time
so your job and this goes back to my
point number one is you have to stand
out
in all of your marketing
because if you don't the group that's
actually looking for you can't see you
in the noise
if there is real or imagined
possibility of
discomfort pain
the break on motivation slams shut
and we start to procrastinate
so we have this incredible system that
can
give us this motivation the motive for
action to go forward but we have to
temper it
with our ability to recognize
the trigger and the
sensation in our body called a feeling
that the non-conscious processing part
of the brain that gives us this emotion
called fear
all fear is processed at the
non-conscious level of your awareness
and then gives rise into the frontal
lobes
of the feeling that your body has the
average person that has not been trained
feels fear
and puts the brake on
and goes and retreats into what they're
comfortable doing
the successful person either they may be
genetically wired to understand feeling
fear and doing it anyway turning their
fear into fuel but that's not the
majority of people that's why 90 plus
percent of people fail and stay in that
position but you can take that fuel that
hypersensitive rocket fuel i
call it and utilize it to actually
motivate you faster further than you
ever got before but it all starts with
being self-obsessed
awareness of when i'm uncomfortable
how do i respond when i'm doubtful how
do i feel when i've got negative
self-talk going on
what's going on when i'm procrastinating
what am i fearful of what am i most
procrastination by the way
is done because of low self-esteem
if you knew how to get something done
you could do it highly effectively and
on time and you were loving it you'd do
it but most people procrastinate because
they feel doubtful they don't have all
the information they're procrastinating
because they're worried that if they
don't do it perfectly somebody's going
to judge them creating
irresistible offers
creating irresistible offers what does
that mean
well it means
that your greatest cost of acquiring a
new customer
is the first sale
and so
have you considered that you can afford
to create an
irresistible offer to get people in
to buy
your first product or service
now whenever we are dealing with
creating irresistible offers let's say
you're selling a pen okay you're selling
a pen
okay
well you can sell the pen let's say for
a dollar right but what if you sold the
pen
and in addition to the pen when you buy
it right now
you also get three videos on how to be a
better writer
three videos on how to take ideas from
your head and craft them in such a way
that people will be
drawn to what you write now a pen can be
sold as a commodity or you can create an
irresistible offer by saying not only am
i going to give you the pen but here is
some added value things that you can use
or need
all right
when you buy my pen now why would you do
that can you imagine why you would do
that
well the hardest sale is the first one
and here's the thing that i want you to
remember
when you trust a brand
and when the brand has a product or
service that meets or exceeds your
expectations
do you continue to buy
from that brand
if the brand exceeds
or meets your expectation
do you buy more from that brand chances
are you do so what does that mean it
means that all of the time and energy
and money that you spent to acquire that
new customer
you don't have to pay for that
acquisition cost
so when
okay
when you acquire a customer and you
deliver or over deliver
not only do they keep coming to buy from
you
but chances are
when they are so happy with what you've
done for them
don't you tell your friends or your
family
so now we have repeat business and we
have referrals
both of which
cost almost no more money the first
three that she gives
are reason
and so
the first of the six steps in rewire
your brain is reason and she says
if you don't give your brain a reason
why like why do you want to do this why
must you do this um
it won't actually want to do the work so
if you don't have a reason why it'll
take the path of least resistance and
come up with the reasons why you
shouldn't faster so that's number one um
second e or second step to re-fire is
engage
and she says when you set a goal she
says engage immerse yourself in your
goal and why you want to achieve that
goal and then get support from a group
or a mentor to keep you engaged as you
level up your knowledge and your skills
and your behaviors
the third of her re fire to rewire out
of the six step process
is
feel
and she said get your emotions behind
your goal she says when you get your
emotions behind your goal by thinking
about all the benefit of everything
you're going to gain who you're going to
become who you're going to be able to
help
how you're growing when you get the
emotion behind it and you engage and you
have your reason why
the emotion is the energy
put into motion
that is required to get the momentum and
keep the momentum going is consistency
across all of your assets so your
business card your landing pages your
ads everything that you can do create
that brand awareness and those colors
and tie it into your name why
well
there's something about our brain
that creates associations so when you
see my face and you see the colors of my
books and you see the colors on my wall
and you see you know our ads or our free
content
or videos
there's a consistent theme
around colors and our brain makes that
connection
across all the channels so when you're
building your personal brand
be thoughtful around what is your
personal brand stand for
then
what are the colors there could be
sounds there's a lot of sounds companies
use um sounds all right to add to the
color scheme to and to the theme
so when we are creating
any type of
messaging
we want there to be something that we
call a banner to buyer consistency
banner to buyer consistency which
actually is going to be the fourth point
so i'll come back to that in just a
moment so i see all of your colors um
yeah when people
when people
um our brain
takes snapshots obviously in a you know
first to create cells of recognition and
when our brain sees consistent colors
over and over and over again it makes
the associations and every single color
means something different to somebody
else so i'm always looking for
consistency
around all of my content i know in my
particular case i didn't believe i
wasn't smart enough because when i moved
at five years old from israel to
montreal i spoke hebrew i didn't read
hebrew or write it but i spoke it i was
just learning the alphabet i was put
into a classroom with 50 kids
all speaking french and english was the
second language they were all speaking
so i sat there for two years looking at
the wall
and not only did i feel stupid and i
remember i'm 55 now so this is 50 years
ago i remember kids spitting on me
in the playground because i couldn't
speak english so i'd get into fights all
the time and end up in the principal's
office my parents would be called into
school your son's not doing well in
school he's having fights with the other
kids and i was frustrated and the
teachers didn't have time to work with
me on teaching me a language god i
didn't know the alphabet so i was two
years behind
for my entire
schooling up until grade 11 when i quit
i said enough is enough so i had
developed this
belief that i wasn't smart enough
holy sh where'd that come from now i
know i'm brilliant and i'm not saying
that in an egotistical way but i studied
quantum physics studying neuroscience i
know sometimes i love it and i can
understand it but the point i want to
make is i developed this pattern in my
brain that i wasn't good enough just
because of my experience as a
and i carried that on for about 15 years
until i was 19
and i had a mentor
you know asked me why do i think i left
school why did i think i was getting in
trouble why was i working for two
dollars and 30 cents an hour when i
clearly could speak and talk and
communicate
um i said well they told me i wasn't
going to amount to much it's only if i
didn't get a college degree i wasn't
going to be smart enough to get a job at
a company and i wouldn't have any
retirement i wouldn't have any ability
to contribute i couldn't make enough
money to take care of myself my family i
believed what what the people that i'm
supposed to believe told me
so i developed this neuron cluster
around my own self-belief that i was not
smart enough and as a result of that
i couldn't do well in the real world so
what did i do from 12 to 17 i lied stole
cheated sold drugs did break in and
entries did counterfeit money uh
whatever i could to make money because
every time you couldn't so i figured out
a way i could
and then i met a man one man
who showed me that i could change my
brain he showed me that i could develop
a new cluster of beliefs that i am good
enough i am worthy enough i am smart if
i can achieve what i want to achieve i
can learn and it's easy for me i can
earn any amount of money i choose i can
learn whatever i need to learn to earn
any amount of money i choose and so i
started at 19
doing daily affirmations i recorded my
affirmations i listened them for
you know two three hours a day in my car
as i was driving i wrote out my goals i
recorded my goals i was taught how to
create a new imprint
into my non-conscious brain which is
where your beliefs are anyway
and i started to read
re-script and reshape my belief patterns
my perception of what's possible and
while i was doing that
my mentor says great let's upgrade your
knowledge and your skills so we raise
your level of confidence and certainty i
want you to read this book i want you to
listen to this audio i want you to do
this i want you to practice one hour a
day on your skills so you get better so
as i raise my self
confidence
and my certainty
and my belief in myself and i developed
some good habits boom one thing started
clicking after another at 19 i made 31
000 bucks at 20 i made 151 000
i started building my own company and
did a billion dollars in sales four
years later so what are you focusing on
are you focusing on why you can't are
you focusing on it's not the right time
are you focusing on i don't have the
time the money the money the energy uh
the knowledge the skills people aren't
buying right now
people aren't buying right now uh things
are so bad what if this happens what if
that happens oh my god what if that
happens if you're in a state of fear
then your
einstein brain's turned off and your
frankenstein brain's turned on and in a
state of fear
you deactivate motivation you deactivate
behavior
that is required to take action right
now so
what you want to do
is you have to
master your mindset
right you have to
stop buying into the
fear-mongering on television and radio
and
so many other places you have to focus
on how you can achieve your financial
goals and your business goals because
you must and because you will and
because you deserve it i want you to
write out just begin writing out a new
money story
and i want you to do this
start off your new money story like this
i'm so grateful and happy for the fact
that
i am now
and and fill in the blanks feeling doing
experiencing having giving just write
out a little
story of your money story and then what
i want you to do every day for the next
just seven days seven days for five
minutes i want you to read that new
money story
even though it's not real right now and
then i want to just imagine what would
it be like
if this was real right now what would it
be like and i want you to feel that just
use that as step one
and see what happens
what will happen is you're gonna do two
things i'm gonna get excited which is
great but you also may hear this little
voice that says that's not true you're
not this you can't that and i want you
to be aware of it without judging it
blaming it shaming it or justifying it
just be aware of it and go holy mackerel
listen to that little inner critic
that is trying to hold me back so let's
say you have some free stuff here
and let's say
you know you're talking about um
i don't know ginsu knives but then over
here you're trying to sell
okay um uh siding for a house there
there has to be a banner to buyer
consistency
around what it is that you are doing and
offering so if you're going to be
talking okay let's say i'm talking about
you know personal branding to build an
income producing business if i was to
all of a sudden say to you hey
does anybody want to go to egypt with me
okay to look at the pyramids you'd be
scratching your head going why was he
talking about branding and then asked me
to go to egypt
if i wanted to take you to egypt i'd be
talking about you know the great
pyramids and the mystical um you know
theme around that and then maybe say
that so whenever you are building your
brand
make sure that you're creating
banner means
any content that you put out whether
it's videos ads infographics or anything
else
right make sure that there is
consistency all the way through to what
you might be offering somebody if you
don't you create brand confusion do you
know what i'm talking about
do you know what i'm talking about so
you want to stand for something and you
want to create consistency now that
doesn't mean that you can't have
different product lines so i'll give you
an example i have a winning the game of
business program i also have a waiting
game a weight loss program but i
wouldn't be talking to business owners
about business growth and then say do
you want to look at my winning game a
weight loss program
if i was doing a session on weight loss
or what i prefer to call weight release
and the science and the evidence of why
people
lose weight and gain weight then it
would make logical sense to offer a
weight loss program so make sure that
you have banner to buyer consistency
across every one of your channels does
that make sense
don't be doing one thing one day another
thing the other day another thing the
other day and another thing the other
day being an adaptationist
being an adaptationist so i want you to
be a mental adaptationist i want you to
be an emotional adaptation yes i want
you to be a business adaptationist
because when you become a business
adaptationist and a mindset an emotional
adaptationist where you adapt and adopt
to the circumstances you control
the environment instead of allowing the
environment to control you mindset is
what separates the best from the rest
right
yes or yes mindset is what separates the
best from the rest right now i've got a
really special bonus clip that i think
you're going to enjoy but before that
it's time for the question of the day i
want to know what was your single
biggest takeaway from this video and
your plan of action for the next week
the sign says that when you just watch a
video you get motivated to get inspired
you have a 35 chance of following
through on your goals 35 that's not
enough that's not enough just to get
motivated believe nation we're here
you're here today matters you're an
action taker
when you commit to a plan of action of
when and how you're going to follow
through when you write it down you have
a 91 chance of following through and
when you commit publicly to somebody
else it jumps to 95 chance from 30
something percent to 95 chance of you
following through believe nation we need
to make this happen so question of the
day your single biggest takeaway from
this video and your plan of action
specific for the next week put it down
in the comments below and i'm going to
show on screen
sometime next week to celebrate you
if somebody has
you know a fear like where is that fear
you know if i have a fear of spiders and
you don't then that means that it's not
the spider okay that's the issue
it's the meaning the pattern that i have
and the associations i have with let's
say spiders that's the issue well where
is that pattern well it's in my
non-conscious brain it's in my brain
well what if i can disrupt that pattern
using technology what if i can disrupt
that pattern using a variety of
evidence-based methodologies whether
it's cognitive behavior therapies
that you listen to and you participate
in
well that is what we're doing we're just
helping people access the parts of their
brain where the patterns exist disrupt
the pattern help them create a new
pattern so that the fear goes away the
emotion of fear
is an effect
right it's it's the feeling
so if we disrupt the pattern we disrupt
the unpleasant feeling that we call fear
so we've learned a variety of different
ways that are all based in neuroscience
and neuropsychology to disrupt patterns
create new patterns faster than ever
before so that people start to feel
better about themselves and about
anything that they want to achieve in
their life
if you want to see my one-on-one
interview with john assaraf check it out
right there next to me i think you'll
love it continue to believe and i'll see
you there do you think i can heal
my broken neck with meditation when when
doctors say it's not going to connect do
you think i can manifest that connection
happening with that bone that broke up
yes